j'espère que le micro fonctionne bien
le raid qui va partir
on va voir on va voir
on va voir si ça marche la caméra je
sais pas pourquoi elle est pas là mais
on va la récupérer
ça a l'air de fonctionner non
on va essayer de récupérer un échiquier
ma caméra
un homme attend il ya toutes les caméras
sur la même partie c'est du foutage de
gueule
la tma l'utilité des caméras quoi
ça sert à quoi en fait
près de caméras sur ce mec
non
agl à lui j'ai rien contre un jeu même
pas qui c'est mais pourquoi je vois pas
froide open vld
j'ai envie de voir carlson toute la
journée en fait ça m'intéresse juste pas
cette fois j'ai trois caméras sur lui
ça sert à quoi je le vois de dos je vois
de face et je le vois de côté
et j'ai une caméra sur n'a qu'à ça sert
à quoi
pourquoi j'ai samoa en fait je veux pas
les voir en fait ils m'intéressent pas
est-ce que je peux enlever la cam
pourquoi je voit en fait
ça c'est un truc j'avais pas envie de te
voir je te vois ça me ça me déconcentre
non java soit à des caméras soit a pas
de caméra ses bords de caméras et demi
sur un joueur et demi
j'en ai à faire
non mais sérieusement
en fait c'est même pas tableau 1 et 2
étapes de magnus parce que magnus il est
une table fixe
on m'avait dit un gogo ne pas utiliser
les camions
mois ya qu un seul homme qui m'intéresse
c'est mme veulent en fait éventuellement
ça va être calmes en petit 1 on va
attendre que maxime arrive montre dans
le tournoi j'ai envie de te dire
bah non mais bon enfin moi j'ai envie
voir maxime en fait les autres je m'en
fous il m'intéresse pas
objectivement j'ai rien contre un il
fait ce qu'il veut mais moi je n'y a
qu'un seul homme qui m'intéresse en fait
très très clairement
vas-y bombe à écouter
petites secondes je vais bien cadré
l'échiquier on va regarder la partie de
maxime
mais ça m'a un peu choqué en fait avoir
que des calmes sur
sur my en fait j'ai été un peu surpris
d'avoir que des calmes sur magnus ou
hikaru désolé les gars mais sa main
ça m'a un peu choqué en fait
il n'y a jamais eu aussi peu de calme en
vrai
bon maxime c'est quoi c'est une petrov
contre hassen qu'enfin il faut commencer
avec une victoire allait jouer table de
toulon et puis s'est terminé 1
le classement de maxim lycée 27 61
bon c'est une position qui est assez
cool à jouer en blitz il va envoyer à
mon avis veut jouer à fond c'est que les
jeux avec petit rock mais bon il va
vouloir jouer la taxe sur le roi
fonctionne ouais ils arrivent en grappe
1 quand même
sauf qu'à suivre car c'est la cas quelle
que soit la table où il joue non mais
vraiment nakai bouge pas de table non
plus
en fait mais bon peu importe 1 c'est
quand même le pays qui regardent le plus
des échecs on peut avoir une cam sur mvl
je ne comprends pas en fait
ça me dépasse en fait je comprends pas
c'est
c'est le pays qui regardent le plus mais
non tu n'as pas la caméra sur ton joueur
d'accord enfin vu
le convoi
ap oui enfin là c'est pas les calmes de
la télé norvégienne et puis même enfin
tu as quand même le droit de montrer
maxfin d'avoir une caméra sur maxime
coppin sait rien en fait de mettre une
caméra
mais en fait même maxime si maxime
joutes à blanc de toute façon en fait
manu s'il est rentable fixe donc ce sera
quand même magnus
toi tu es français une caméra sur une
veine les polonais qui verrait bien une
caméra sur krasnenkov c'est juste
partial en fait ils mettre les meilleurs
c'est tout mais pas les meilleurs ils
ont deux caméras ils ont deux tables pas
une question d'être les meilleurs vins
chers au bout d'un moment c'est comme si
on ligue 1 tu as neuf matches d'affilée
et disent à mon monde qu'un match bas un
an fin du film les neuf matchs
tu mets les meilleurs vins
du monde tu m'as aussi les gens qui
regardent le plus quoi
ça
ramène que de l'eau à mon moulin de dire
qu'il faudrait des formats coupées et
des choses où tu peux vraiment voir du
spectacle de la la la on
[Musique]
pas je ne sais pas comment on dira quoi
enfin ces tutus sans le côté non
spectaculaire et anti climatiques du
délire en fait
très franchement je veux récupérer ma
came aussi on va suivre ce tournoi
tranquillement juste il me fallait
encaisser le choc
donc
il a fait face
sa
as
il a raté x 6 maximum et fois ci c'est
pas un coup que tu joues
c'est moi ça me désespère pour les
échecs en fait mais un maxime il a pas
une super post 20 pas une super pause il
n'a pas forcément pris l'avantagé va
regarder des trucs comme fou prend
cavaliers 4 1 qui peuvent passer
d'un match 4
ok
je vous cette petite finale maxime il
menace qui étrangers 6 quand même marlou
qu'elle tente un coup un piège
dans un petit piège ce qui le menace
vraiment d'ailleurs sait pas sur qui le
menace est vraiment sur quel point les
quatre cavaliers f5 fou prend avec lui
trois points fit cavalier f3
b4
ok c'est pas bien maxime en fait parce
que ça tape ces deux et il a pas
vraiment tour d2 il ya tout reprend d2
et qui avale et prend tout re 2
je sais pas ça donne pas du tout envie à
du fou c'est cathy doit faire tour c1
guinée c'est pas illogique ah non mais
c'est face est normal que sur un
championnat du monde n'est que de deux
joueurs qu'ils soient filmés alors que
tu mets une go pro x est hyper facile
d'avoir les caméras sur les 10 premiers
échiquiers je ne demande pas tant que ça
tu mets sur les 10 premiers tu peux
enfin c'est quand même pas très dur en
vrai c'est facile
mais bon si vous trouvez que c'est que
c'est bien c'est tant mieux enfin
peut-être nous filmons même plus et ne
mettons même plus les coûts en fait un
fin bientôt le fait que les coûts arrive
complètement décalé ça va être bien le
fait qu'on n'ait pas les pendules normal
le les temps ça va être bien aussi fait
un tout et bien en fait mais ça c'est
comme toujours en fait on se contentait
de la médiocrité s'est passé pas mon
leitmotiv un
tube et les dix premiers échiquiers
c'est bien
bah oui alors à la limite tu mets juste
les résultats à la fin des parties là ça
bug on peut même pas avoir la partie en
vrai on peut même pas l'avoir
d'un moment aussi c'est bien les coups
qui viennent en grappe le machin on peut
rien voir ou quoi fin tant mieux mais
moi je trouve pas ça acceptable
c'est terrible on peut pas réellement
pas voir la partie les amis en
malheureusement je suis vraiment désolé
mais c'est comme ça
mon mac similaire un peu mieux la whey
tout d'un coup
maxime il a pas l'air si mal
à
ouais s'ils rejettent à puy saint cette
voix là j'ai pas j'ai pas les coûts en
fait enfin je sais pas quoi vous dire
j'ai pas les coûts et les partis qui se
finissent à droite on n'a pas découvert
un c c'est difficile en fait
c'est très difficile je veux aller sur
follow chess et je vais les regarder sur
follow de chasse en fait un et je vais
vous dire ce qui se passe on va faire on
va faire un podcast en fait les amis on
va faire on va faire du nouveau
on va faire un podcast
et je vais vous dire ce que je vois
ouais ouais à maxime la police ne
regarde pas ce qui à l'écran les amis
maxime maxime qui attend les maximes et
les goûts c'est bon j'ai la partie de
mon max on en est où il ya un pion de
plus pour maxi et maxime qui met un
échec le plus rage de maxime qui est
passé au et maxime qui tente une
tactique il est peut-être en train de
gagner une pièce le joueur français voit
le joueur polonais qui se défend il
tenta un piège y contratas kallel dame
maxime un pion passer tout seul en match
il peut l'envoyer attention ils
échangent des tours on rentre dans une
finale de fou contre cavaliers ya le
plus rage qui part pour maxime ou à son
adversaire grâce n comme sommes pas en
possibilités de l'art et espion on ya
droit qui revient maxime qui va avoir
peut-être deux pions passé maxime maxime
qui à deux doigts de gagner un deuxième
pion aidé à les envoyer un un duo de
pions passer à l'est le roi il semble
complètement gagnant le français ça y
est il s'en prend fin au cavalier
lecavalier qui protège le dernier pour
le dernier rempart des noirs le cavalier
qui s'échappe et va chercher le contrôle
jalel dame maxime maxime qu'à ses deux
pions ses deux pions passé qui avance le
contre jeu des noirs ne semble pas
suffisant krasnenkov en grande
difficulté il est en train de ramener
toutes ces pièces pour défendre les
maximes qui pousse attention il n'a pas
le bon piont il n'a pas le bon plus aux
maximes mais ça devrait ça devrait
s'adorer fiable il suffire quand même il
a encore sont plombées de l'autre côté
qui va pouvoir faire dame grâce à une
coque qui tente une défense désespérée
mais ça y est ça y est le français en
train de mener sa sa part tient bien et
c'est l'abandon pour casser le kof
victoire de maxime maximilian la
première partie les amis moi je vous
propose qu'on commande ça en mode radio
1 enfin il y en a plus rien à [ __ ] en
fait il ya plus d'échiquier ya plus rien
à ce championnat du monde va être grand
ça va être de la radio c'est en podcast
les amis aujourd'hui il n'ya pas les
couilles pas les coups ça va être un
podcast on va se faire une petite
journée de podcasts on va kiffer c'est
du podcast
victoire de maxime vachier lagrave on
vous allez voir la position qui va
arriver avec une demi heure de retard
ça a été extraordinaire cet incident je
remonte la partie en rapide pour ceux
qui n'ont pas vu c'est un format radio
moi je vais regarder les parties et puis
vous aurez ce que vous pourrez avoir
et on fera ce qu'on peut mais ça va être
commentée comme ça toute la journée
j'annonce
j'annonce ça va être commentée comme ça
toute la journée en face on n'y a rien à
faire
et ce que je dis à jesse comme que comme
on n'a pas les coûts et les camions mais
pas de pub
est ce que ça se fout ça se fait pas
pas de cap ou pas de pub
ça paraît faire donc comme deal
ou pas ça paraît faire nous ça paraît
pas faire
ben je sais pas un
david wood la fin alors je vais vous
donner quelques résultats quand même
on va essayer d'avoir quelques résultats
magnus carlsen qui a battu corrales
nakamura
il était complètement foutu c'est
terrible
il était complètement fou tu n'as qu'à
il apprend des trois
ils ont dû faire annuler je pense
d'ailleurs
ses droits aussi maxime va peut-être
arriver tableau de rapidement en fait
j'ai roulé
un truc
entre gare eev
volo kittin caruana sa durée doit en
fait maxime va déjà jouer tableau 2
presque
m
dit camille à 5 camilia 3 calme sur le
championnat du monde mx t2 sur le
championnat du monde hommes
il ya réellement trois caméras quoi
c'est terrible
le faire en mode radio 1 regardez ça
comme un podcast
il ya un championnat du monde mx1
championnat du monde fabre et
ça car la prochaine games à 15h30 je
pense
ce
que je peux pas le faire en fait quand
je suis sur ma chaîne je peux mais c'est
pas on va faire un mode radio 1
c'est qu'il arrive là c'est vraiment sûr
de chasse comme que ça arrive pas
enfin ça arrive sur sur follow chess
c'est pas clean clean non plus hein
c'est pas pas super super mais on voit
les parties quand même
voilà pa je suis pas sur ma chaîne du
coup je peux pas faire ce que je veux
comme d'habitude
on était censé profiter des cas mais on
n'y arrive pas trop non plus c'est un
peu la cata quoi
et pas un problème de chasse comme par
contre il y en a vraiment pas beaucoup
taschen mais en fait ma chaîne tu vois
bien qu'il ya départ en ligne enfin
réfléchit c'est quoi non là je suis qui
est bloquant
ont écouté ça va ça sert à rien de façon
qu'est-ce que tu qu'on y fasse
maintenant c'est comme ça
on peut rien y faire un on peut plus
rien changer maintenant c'est parti
comme ça
quel suivi y faire
comme ça que tu y as pas le choix on va
tenter un nouveau truc
on va tenter un nouveau truc ce
paragraphe sera marrant on commentera
sent les coups c'est pas grave on n'a
peut-être pas besoin de voir de voir la
partie 1
c'est mon écran et refaire les coupes
non mais bon je vais pas refaire les
coups un parent est regardé comme ça
pour vous montrer les couffins on va pas
faire un live de montres h de course ça
va rien c'est complètement ridicule
j'sais pas moi je réécoutais bien les
matchs de foot à la radio un
façon il ya j'imagine que la majorité
des gens qui regardent le live et
regarde pas l'écran en vrai
c'est un genre de podcasts en vrai on va
faire un podcast et puis c'est tout un
qu'est ce que tu veux
la paix gens qui travaillent en même
temps qu'ils sont en voiture qui sont en
mach 1 d'autres qui jouent à des jeux
vidéo en même temps chacun fait son truc
un certain vrai coup de tête de la
musique j'en sais rien
mon avis sur le nombre de gens tiens on
va on va faire un petit pote mais je
pense la plupart des gens ne regardent
pas l'écran
je pense
je pense que la plupart des gens sont
juste en écoute
je pense j'envoie le vote le problème
c'est qu'il va être biaisé parce qu'il
ya des gens qui s'y qui regarde pas les
crampons pavon pas répondre
mais même en étant fausse et je suis sûr
qu'il va y avoir beaucoup de noms
et
même là il ya plein de gens qui votent
non j'écoute
petit à petit on regarde mais donc du
coup vous regardez pas forcément hyper
attentivement
vous regardez pas forcément hyper
k
de stream sur l'avenir et stringer
taschen
ah ouais ouais après le truc c'est que
ça c'était avantageux d'avoir les calmes
pour les championnats du monde pour les
candidats ou quoi mais c'est vrai que
quand c'est comme ça s'ajuste aucun
intérêt quoi
alors vraiment
peut-être si maxime joue bien il va
arriver table 1 et 2 et on sera très
content mais là en début de tournoi
c'est vrai que c'est complexe
max stade iii phase i mac ça arrive
table de après on aura max on sera
tranquille si max joue bien
mais ce que table de ils vont tout le
temps mes tricks arous est aussi
possible
mais déjà on va peut-être à voir sur
l'eau truc de che score où il met que
trois tables mais où la retransmission
est meilleur en fait on va peut-être
avoir s'ils restent assez tablas on va
peut-être avoir les coups après
en vous et
s'ils jouent dans les premières tables
ça peut être notre chance
donc si roux qui a perdu 1 contre carrer
f bon c'est pas prêt enfin c'est pas
bien de commencer ce soir par une
défaite mais je ne sais pas gravissime
au caire ils sont très heureux
je demandé une cam
pour cette partie on voir les coûts
on
va voir on va changer d j'y tiens
ils vont essayer de récupérer une cam
sur sur un nouvelle quand même
on va essayer d'avoir une caméra sur mv
elle
va peut-être réussir à voir ce qu'on
veut quand même
j'ai tout le temps aller pour avoir des
trucs même qu'ils sont au minimum
c'est terrible
tenté
il est possible qu'on réussisse à faire
allumer une caméra
il est possible
il est possible qu'on soit qu'on soit
capable de réussir alors faire allumer
une des caméras qui sont là pour réussir
à la récupérer
on devra simon
olalalala alors c'est magnifique c'est
magnifique il est là rolala la caisse
qu'il est beau c'est incroyable
c'est incroyable oh que oui oh que oui
il est beaucoup trop beau un procès
terrible
voilà on va voir on va voir que maximin
j'annonce un attendait faut que je
récupère le bon petit échiquier
pour avoir les coûts
pour les qu'on les aura peut-être pas me
parle balech
pas le plus important les coûts en fait
je vois pas la partie j'ai pas la game
attendait
à meyrin est un joueur avec les coûts en
fait c'est pas forcément les mêmes
mais c'est pas grave on voit la position
là
à temps écrit un petit truc
les deux façons
on peut on peut suivre on voit on voit
quand même assez bien la l'échiquier on
le voit bien donc on peut on peut
regarder sur l'échiquier en grand en
fait
je récupère de la voix
magnifique
alley maximin aller maxime
il faut il joue contre eux qui
voulaient que va se ruiner ne connaît
pas allez il faut lui mettre le punto à
oleg aller fois l'ailé qu'il faut faut
aller le chercher au legs à laymont
maxime allais montbard loup on va plus
le quitter et maxime
faut qu'il aille le chercher là projet
tellement vite qu'il fasse un plaquage
ces mêmes avant la partie vient et met
la table dans dans le bide là
ça ferait du bien
est un petit coup là bas il faut qu'il
aille le chercher
table numéro 3 déjà maximale et ça
commence il va nous faire quoi le frérot
au cavaliere 3 oh ça va pas faire peur
aux ministres un petit dessine koki par
g3 ça va faire du fian kétou maxime qui
envoie du g6 yankee est aussi fou geste
fou j'ai deux foulées set ça jouer dans
le style de sa grünfeld rock la position
va être symétrique après petit rock des
noirs pour le moment il ya ya rien qui
est fait dans cette partie qui a et b d2
il vient contrôler le centre le joueur
russe maxim qui exit il a plusieurs
options fouet f5 c5 ça c'est des coups
dans dans son règne il peut aussi jouer
du petit c6 il ya aussi piscine quo dans
le règne de mao c'est la simko qui part
ça commence à attaquer déjà allèles dame
côté maxime il a envoyé son punto là bas
tout au bout tout au fond et il va aller
commencer à mettre un peu de pression
maxime qui réfléchit après tout un foin
f5 qui vient contrôler la la case de
quatre cavaliers h4 son adversaire qui
vient s'en prendre à son fils maxime qui
va tranquillement le recul est en aussi
c'est maintenant il a l'air bien bête
oleg avec son cavalier en h4 et oui
maxime lui a fait la petite fan du
facteur je viens la f5 et non non je
venais en russie ce tueur retourne en f3
et puis on verra ce qu'on fait son
adversaire menant au lac qui essaye de
jouer solide il envoie un petit c3 et
consolide son centre maxime qui va qui
va devoir
mettre la pression il hésite à faire un
sitting cola il hésite ici reprend à
deux fois peut-être qu'il va sortir son
cavalier b8 qui encore au bercail il va
falloir aller se développe et peut-être
sur 17 peut-être sur a6
maxime qui a une longue concentration il
prend son temps aujourd'hui on sent
qu'il a vraiment envie de faire un
résultat il a envie de nous montrer
qu'il est capable capable d'aller gagner
un championnat du monde il est capable
de ne pas gâcher une seule munition et
maintenant il met cavaillon à 6 il va
aller chercher le pion c5 et vallées
jaillir vers la case de 400 adversaire
qui joue qu'à et b3 qui le tient à
catherine de chasse cahier des cats il
vient attaquer le fou et 6 hossa éternue
attention attention il est pas masquer
le frérot ils essayent de mikron de le
favori du tournoi cavaliers français 5
le cavalier de maxime qui revient il
défend le pion le pion aux six le de
l'oeuf ou 1,6 pour reprendre du cavalier
pardon
cavaliers pros et 6 maxime qui va
reprendre du cheval au legs qui est
content d'avoir gagné la paire de foule
et maxime à ces deux cavaliers plantés
ont aussi cf6 qui contrôle complètement
le centre et il ya ce pion à 4 qui peut
aussi faire mal maxime qui va peut-être
aller décalé saddam sur la case b6 pour
aller mettre pression sur le pion b2 et
continuer à
attaquer les dames adverse en tout cas
pour le monde c'est solide côté russe ça
fait pas d'erreur maxime qui met
justement cette dame en b 6 il tape b 2e
étape f2 le cavalier qui peut rejaillir
en a eu quatre
alors qu'on a un petit double a qui
arrivent remercie le frérot jean-michel
cadrage qui fait le travail wow c'est du
cadrage de très très haut niveau
peut-être le cavalier qui va partir aux
quatre peut-être des cavaliers français
13 qui peuvent qui peuvent partir en
tout cas ça joue côté côté maxime plus
qu'une minute 50 comptes devant son
adversaire réussisse a réussi à résister
à la marle ou trios adverses tensions et
les galères en forme en ce début de
tournoi c'est peut-être la partie de sa
vie en pour oleg il n'a peut-être jamais
jouer un joueur aussi fort mais elle
prend ses trois qui part j'ai dû rater
quelque chose on voit pas de loin
cavaliers décati résiste pour le moment
au legs au lait qui fait peut-être un
vraiment sans rigoler en retrait la
meilleure partie de son existence
maxime qui réussit pas à faire l'écart
pour le moment deux cavalières si ça
reste solide pour pour oleg il a il
al'avantage de la paire de fou mais son
pousseur et ans fermé derrière sa chaîne
de pions
avec solid 2 minutes s'il réussit à
maintenir la distance la cadence de
pédalage du joueur français mais le fou
c'est un maintenant et ont fermé et
maxime va tenter de jouer sur la case de
4 à l'est il prend aussi ce maxime qui
reprend de la dame on sait pas doubler
les pions attention fait pas tomber tes
pièces frérot même en dehors de
l'échiquier c'est bien il a replacé et
maxime qui maintenant va installer un
cavalier e 4 il est tranquille il boit
une petite gorgée d'eau de joueurs
français il est il est serein il est
william saurin les amis il ya peut-être
du pion à 2 qui peut tomber sur dd
quattro il ya peut-être dubé sinko qui
part il n'y a plus qu'une 40 pour oleg
oleg qui peut se mettre mal autant
maintenant il commence à piocher au legs
il pioche il pioche y pioche du temps ça
peut ça peut lui coûter cher il joue p3
ils essayent de sortir des griffes du
joueur français et il veut peut-être
sourire la colonne b pour pour aller
mettre la pression sur le pion b cette
maxime qui fait cavalier cathy met la
pression sur ses 3 il veut essayer de
gagner ce fou de cases blanches et
essayer d'aller faire un jeu sur blanc
avec fou prend dame prend peut-être h 5
h 4 après pour aller mettre la pression
sur ce roi j'ai un bien esseulé sur sur
les droits ils feront eux 4 maxime peut
aussi reprendre du pillon et wii prend
du plomb il donne la case d3 il ya une
tour qui va débarquer en d3 et maxime
qui est en train de prendre l'aventage
maintenant la tour qui va venir en d3 ça
va doubler avec ton des huit c'est en
train d'arriver de tous les côtés hawley
qui apporte à faire face à maxime il
prend quand même son temps le français
avant d'envoyer cette tour en d3 on est
là les amis on n'est pas loin il est pas
loin de l' avantage maxime ici et il
envoie là tout en d3 il attaque le pion
c3 le pion qui prend à 4 maxime qui peut
prendre ces trois intermédiaires
peut-être peut-être peut-être un fou
prend ces 3 ou 1 to reprend ses trois on
va voir les amis le pion c3 qui va
tomber il prendre la tour y gagne un
tempo sur la dame la dame qui est
parents en deuil a maintenant à quatre
qui tombait ya deux derrière et il ya
deux derrière les amis ils en train
d'aller se le prendre il est en train de
l'aller les a gagné tout seul la partie
a surtout prend à katia encore peut-être
dû contre jeu sur la huitième attention
tout point à 87,3 de tourbe et 8 échecs
ça peut être dangereux
maxime qui réfléchit tour c'est cette
solide il défend le pion
il a bien pris son temps il lui reste
plus de 40 secondes contre une minute 10
mai maxime est capable d'accélérations
titanesque le fou qui vient b2 il
accepte d'avoir un pion moins olé qu'il
va tenter de défendre cette finale vous
prend g7 tout reprendre intermédiaire ya
pas la foulée de retour maxime qui
évidemment le voit il prend du roi et au
lait qui va essayer d'aller tire la
finale tourbe et de ses solides côté
oleg c'est très solide côté au lait avec
ces solides côté russe mais maxime un
pion de plus alors que jean-michel
travelling est en train de s'amuser pour
nous faire gerber tour c40 on voit plus
l'échiquier qu'est ce que tu fais qu'est
ce que tu fais la tour qui vient c'est 4
maxime qui double il va peut-être
essayer de venir en c2 il ya peut-être
dû h5 qui va partir elle n'est pas
facile à gagner celle-là pour maxime il
envoie le h100 qui va y avoir 1 h 4 sont
tannés de la part de son adversaire
maxime qui va peut-être devoir tenter de
jouer avec un tour c'est sain qu'un pion
en b 5 pour avancer pour pouvoir
coulisses et peut-être avec tours f5
maxime qui est mieux maxime qui
al'avantage lui maxime qui n'est pas
encore gagnant son adversaire et robuste
je dirais même robuste au maximum maxime
qui réfléchit attention les secondes
s'égrènent il va peut-être se mettre mal
autant mais il est il est impliqué il
réfléchit il est fort dame f5 pour b 5
tours ses 5 îles en train d'avancer
maxime son adversaire qui essaye de
tenir avec une tour en b1 il contre
attaque sur le plomber cette maxime qui
envoie la tour en c5 il a vu quelque
chose maxime surtout reprend bessette il
à tour ces deux et il va attaquer sur
les cases f3 à f2 son adversaire en
grande difficulté maintenant le pion qui
va partir en bessin qu il faut résister
côté oleg olé qui réfléchit qui prend
son temps il a l'air dubitatif
il sait plus comment défendre les amis
mais il est encore là pour le moment
attention il réfléchit prend son temps
il prend son temps au legs il va essayer
de trouver un coup de défensive et une
tour en d1 et l'a peut-être un petit peu
en bessin qui peut partir maxime qui va
pouvoir remettre la marche avant enfin
voilà ça y est le pion est tombé 5 tout
est sécurisé il va falloir maintenant
trouver là la faiblesse dans la carapace
d'oleg oleg qui tient au legs au lait
qui tient son terrain il commence à
réfléchir il réfléchit un petit peu trop
maintenant plus que 25 secondes je crois
pour oleg il vient blindés sur la
colonne des maximes qui jouent eux six
mais il va avoir du mal à avancer tour
des huit un coup un petit peu surprenant
il laisse la tour en transe et de mes
vagues il va colmater avec tours d2 ça
va échanger une paire de tours y
réfléchit quand même parce qu'il a
peut-être peur de tours c'est un maxime
qui échangent une paire de tours encore
une réflexion coteaux la caisse qui
prend de la dame laisserait dames et
trois échecs mais il aura peut-être
d'amd 4 non un petit peu plus très bien
reprendre de la tour maxime qui sait
toujours pas comment passer mais la tour
en dessins qui peut rentrer dans une
finale de dame et la tournée pendant des
heures oleg qui hésite il prend maxime
qui reprend de l'adami va voir du dam
des trois maintenant dans son riche dame
b2i mais un échec maxime qui pousse le
pion aux 5 il vient par et l'échec au
lait qui met sa dame en bécane devant le
pion maxime maxime dames c'est qu'à
propose les changes attention risque il
est dans le carré il est juste dans le
carré dames cette collecte qui vient
contre attaquer sur le roi de maxime dam
des saints qui vient contrer à trois
salaires des tenues les amis au lait qui
est en train de la tenir roy g8 maxime
qui prend un échec il n'arrive pas
vraiment à progresser on voit qu'il
hésite maxime trois sets s'il veut
tenter une marlou tri ça se sent on
connait l'attitude du joueur français
mais là est ce qui peut mettre la dame
en russie pour entrer dans cette finale
non il peut pas vraiment il a un petit
peu dégoûté f5 un coup un petit peu
risqué il devrait y avoir un échec
perpétuelle maintenant pour son
adversaire maxime va tenter de monter
son roi mais il ne peut pas non il
accepte la nulle c'est bien joué bravo
l'est qui aura réussi à défendre une
position très difficile
mamba null null de combat les amis
nul de combat belle partie
solide les gains très solides
maxime qui rempli la feuille de partie
et c'est le match nul
nice a su ça sue jane parti dans 20
minutes va falloir que je me repose un
petit peu parce que j'ai pu avoir de
voix ce soir
méfier route je ne sais pas
s'ils ont déjà nul contre billère
l'entrevue la game bah non mais lorient
de faire la fin je peux pas te faire le
commentaire te review les game ça va pas
être possible
complexe
ont malheureusement n'aura peut-être pas
les calmes pour la prochaine on verra je
sais pas encore je peux pas vous dire je
sais pas
un petit pub un
petit pub
petite pub
je vais aller je vais aller me refaire
un peu de thé je reviens
je reviens dans une petite minute
alors on en est où
est parti c'est toutes les demi-heures
en fait
car la game de magnus ah ouais on va
jeter un oeil j'ai pas trop ce qui s'est
passé dans les autres partis
manu s'il a gagné ça
gagnant on devrait déjà
tout acquis a perdu contre des mines off
bhl
et n'a qu'à il était où
ak il a gagné la deuxième
fire il a gagné je pense qu'il peut être
rendre fire le premier jour mais il
arrivera pas à tenir les deux jours en
entier je pense
d'avoir beaucoup de joueurs à 2 sur 2
encore un dia relief il a deux sur deux
simon
contre eux qui jouent
gagner je sais pas qui c'est mais elle
joue le tournoi mixte
riches à 2 sur devrait y avoir beaucoup
jour à 2 sur 2 encore mais un ennemi
pour maxime c'est pas malin en vrai ça
va
vingt-six jours à 2 sur de vrais noms
c'est sûr il ya encore plein de pleins
de gags sur deux ans 20 c
il va y avoir un écrémage qui va être
assez long lors des 8 9 premières
parties après doit rester que les
meilleurs en eau
wen au maximum a bien joué il a mis la
pression
on sera là je pense que ça va être
impossible s'il est trop loin dans leur
façon mais la vrai dire c'est normal une
fois qu'il a dépassé table 10 je dis
rien
là c'est juste dommage de ne pas avoir
les dix premières tables après
après la 1 et demi
quelques en quelque sorte c'est normal
de ne pas la voir
et mazet joue pas non il a annulé je
sais pas s'il y aller mais il a annulé
le tournoi en tout cas
en tout cas elle a annulé le tournoi
voyez pas aller du tout à mathieu c'est
dommage un
fait tout annuler la libye devait y
aller aussi l'annuler
mvt paris nov ouais je sais pas en blitz
ça doit aller jamais un joueur facile
mais je pense sans vie de sa vallée
et firent où il a un demi point donc il
est vraiment distancés pour le moment
mais il va remonter là il ya vraiment le
temps de remonter dans ces tournois
regardez partie d un peu on joue pas je
regarderai pas en fait je regarderai pas
le tour a fait bien jouer le ton à mx
donc s'il ya une femme qui arrive dans
les premières tables on regardera ya
aucun problème mais je vais rester sur
le ton est mixte
pas non
mais s'il y en a qui arrivent dans les
premières tables je regarderai il ya
vraiment aucun souci
au contraire même d'ailleurs quand il y
avait eu carnage qui naquit le
championnat de russie mix on avait pas
mal regardé
d'ailleurs
donc
on va essayer de récupérer chasse comme
ils vont essayer de mettre les parties
de maxime en priorité sur le truc qui
bug pas
qu'on réussit quand même à obtenir ce
qu'on veut hein
on est saddam en un ouais mais il était
complètement foutu puis quand tu as une
seconde à la pendule tu cliques 1
enfin qui veulent passer vie dit ouais
hein qui bug -
on va être précis dans l'appellation du
truc
on va la voir sur le truc qui bug moi
c'est ça le truc qui bug moi on va
l'avoir
on va faire ce qu'on peut hein
on va faire
on va essayer de faire ce qu'on peut
j'ai pas trop à l'écart on va on va
décider ce qu'on met comme comme
installation
donc on va attendre les partis qui
devraient reprendre
dans cinq minutes
ce que j'aurai wind des gammes je
déplaçais abbaoui j'aurais pas fait zéro
point non plus mais j'aurais pas fait
beaucoup je pas j'aurais peut-être fait
6 sur 23 un truc comme ça
quelque chose quelque chose dans strange
là
bon comme tu joues pas pour gagner le
tournoi sera rien si tu joues pas pour
top 1 ou au mieux top froissart aqua d'y
aller en fait
rien et une réponse
bonsoir une piste de niveau avec un
échiquier virtuel au réel ça j'y crois
parce que en fait j'imagine que si tu
t'entraînes regarde abdou soit hors à
fond dit il est très fort sur internet
dont il est aussi champion du monde sur
l'échiquier réel
j'y crois pas trop à ce truc là
si t'as pas là tout ça peut faire une
différence mais si tu as l'habitude
je pense pas que ça change grand chose
honnêtement
en certains la chance de prendre des
tops mondiaux peut-être un
je ne sais pas je peux pas te dire
bon ça va
droit
marrante cette gamme
c'est martirossian non
non
je passe light sans lui ressemblera pas
à mes oreilles ça ressemble un peu
là c'est gris choc
l'aca est magnus
je sais pas
on va se battre comme ça alors
en espérant qu'on est bien les coups
je suis sûr à promotionner pions comme
s'ils font 3 damas je sais pas un
temps récupéré une autre au hasard
pas mal d'échiquier autour
16h
tu mets une tour à l'envers ou la non ça
non c'est une tour à l'envers c'est
considéré comme une tour
à ne surtout pas faire on tourne grâce à
la tour à l'envers
tu peux le faire mais ça a bougé comme
une tour après
ça c'est un m
ça va partir
je vais faire un dernier chèque sur les
caméras mais c'est sûr qu'on a pas
maxime
on va attendre 1
ça à partir
les coûts ou pas
la question c'est ce qu'on va voir les
coûts est ce qu'on va commenter sans
voir les coûts du tout
d'un côté ou l'autre on va se
débrouiller
on va très bientôt le savoir les amis
on nous les coûts
ou pas
les yeux rivés sur sur les sur les sites
on a les couilles nulle part pour le
moment donc déjà le bug est globale
ok on a les coûts les amis donc il ya eu
4 ou 5 maxime qui a pris le centre qui a
joué une espagnole ouais ça par sa part
dans les grandes variantes chez par
innove qui a fait petit rock qui a
essayé trois fous et 6 le cavaly de
maxime qui va probablement aller vers
des cimes coteaux ou tard il ya aussi
fou et trois dans cette position jouable
ouais il envoie le cavalier en d6 qu il
n'ya pas cavaler prend plus on prend ça
fait fourchette sur fou prend il pourra
reprendre cahier des 4 il y avait
peut-être une de ces parties contre
dingli rennes qui ressemblait à ça qui
m'a dit qu'il va prendre s il se prend
dans des 4 et jouer et jouer une
structure intéressante vous allez le
voir maxime c'est une position qui
maîtrise très bien ces deux parties
intéressantes c'est une partie
importante intéressante et importante
pour maxime il a besoin de gagner au
blanc de prendre la confiance
d'enchaîner les bons résultats maxime
c'est un joueur qui marche qui marchent
aussi à ça et il a un grand besoin de
bien rentrer dans le tournoi il a fait
une bonne première partie la deuxième il
a réussi à prendre l'avantagé mais il
n'a pas pu conclure et là ça va être un
petit peu le révélateur chez par enough
j'ai envie de dire si réussi à le battre
il va complètement se lancer dans cette
journée si s'ils trébuchent ça pourrait
mettre le joueur mettre le doute dans la
dans la tête du joueur français et le
mettre en difficulté pour le reste de la
journée en tout cas pour le moment ces
genres de position qui maîtrise très
bien ces espagnols avec des pions doublé
au centre un petit peu bizarre mais
c'est maxime qui a la main sur
l'échiquier c'est lui qui va pouvoir
développer sa dame en f3 sortir son
fonds f4 et réussira à s'activer plus
rapidement il peut aussi jouer pour du
fou des deux fois cinq îles à la tour
qui peut venir en e1 c'est une position
qui est agréable à jouer pour les blancs
et c'est une position qu'il a l'habitude
d'avoir qu'il a l'habitude de jouer
après d'un produit complètement objectif
il ya probablement rien du tout pour les
blancs mais on espère y mais la dame en
f3 il tape un petit peu sur la sur le
fou les noirs qui vont protéger
probablement par dame 17 il défend son
fou peut-être un petit tour aux reins
qui menacera peut-être détour prendre
cette d'impro f5 il commence par food et
2 pour le moment il va mettre la tour il
va doubler sur sur la colonne eux le
joueur français et il a une position qui
lui plaît peut-être qu'il va se
permettre de faire un petit h 3 c'est
d'ailleurs ce qu'ils jouent
prophylactique ils empêchent les fous
j'ai quatre ils empêchent les maths du
couloir et il va très bientôt envoyé une
tour sur e1 probablement la tour f ou
bien jouer pour un autre plan le plan
tour à 3 toi que je les ai déjà vus
aussi employé dans ce jeu deux positions
chez paris nos flics de côté noir qui a
une position assez robuste lui aussi
mais il a peu de plans pour mettre la
pression sur maxime pour le moment
qu'ils s'apprêtent à échanger une tour
il reprendra probablement du fou avec
l'idée de mettre après la pression sur
la colonne a avec la tour restantes chez
par innove qui fait face à un choix
maintenant est ce qu'ils échangent les
tours ou pas c'est la question qui doit
se poser et pourrait simplement aussi
joué un coup comme fou j'ai six pour
replacer son fou enlevés
libérez la dame de sa tâche défensive et
éventuellement venir même lui même en
rêve 5 pour échanger les dames chez par
innove qui prend son temps qui prend son
temps c'est le cas de le dire il lui
reste une minute 50
contre 2 minutes 09 pour maxime les
temps que vous voyez à droite ne sont
pas bons je le saurai pour la prochaine
partie à jeu même pouvoir afficher les
temps correct laissez moi une petite
seconde voilà comme ça on a les bons
tant qu'ils sont au dessus et en dessous
c'est quand même plus agréable et donc
maxime après tourcoing qui a joué fou
prend 1 maxime qui menace maintenant qu
on prend n'y aurait pas pu on prend à
cause de tour points à 8 sur puis on
prend b5 dame prend b5 le pion à 6
serait isolé on va voir maintenant ce
que je sais par enough décide de faire
rimer la tour en 1 8 kg on prend les
cinq pions prend b5 et maxime qui va
probablement me décaler son fou en d2
c'est chose faite pour s'enlever de la
menace a eu un éventuellement jouer tour
à cette fois 5 le fou de chez par innove
qui parlons g6 et maxime qui va
probablement envoyé sa tour en a 7 et
qui va mettre la pression sur le pion
c'est cette maxime quelle position
légèrement avantageuse mais les noirs
sont très solides il envoie h5
maintenant chez paris 9eme pression
allait droit maxime qui va sûrement
voyez un fou en a thing qu est une
menace à présent tout reprend ses 7 j
par innove qui va devoir part et la
menace il va sûrement jouer un coup
comme food et 8,1 coups de recul qui va
défendre le pion mais qui va baisser son
activité il fait tour ses huit donc
maintenant les noirs n'ont plus l'appui
sur la colonne e maxime qui va pouvoir
venir se décale et peut-être avec la
dame est ce qu'il va jouer une dame en
e2 pour gagner le contrôle de cette
colonne en tout cas à court terme et
peut-être après se décaler vers un bep 4
est allé chercher des menaces à l'ale
dames y reste encore une minute trente à
maxime qui est un petit avantage à la
pendule il va falloir réussir à le faire
parler tôt ou tard maxime qui prend son
temps
et on va voir quelle quelle décision il
prend c'est vrai que la position noir
est solide il est difficile de créer une
menace
alors qu'on voit la caméra que griche
hook et et duda ont terminé leur leur
parti
maxime qui mêleront f1 alors est-ce qui
part avec un plan aux longues ou locaux
au long cours pardon d'année son rang b
un plan extraordinaire joué par maxime
roy ait fait un roi ou un roi des rois
c'est un roi b1 rolala il en est une
grosse une grosse paire pour maxime il
part avec un plan original 3f et un roi
au roi des huns et il veut du roi c'est
un roi b1 par la suite
c'est assez extraordinaire ce qu'il est
en train de faire l'ordinateur n'aime
pas du tout mais honnêtement leurs dix
tours c'est eu tour à tour eu huit tours
5 ce ne sera jamais joué maxime qui va
pouvoir tranquillement mettre son rang b
1 et après attaque est allé droit non
mais c'est le genre de plan qui fait mal
à des joueurs du calibre de che par
enough pas assez fort avec aussi peu de
temps pour contrer l'originalité du
joueur français peut-être qu'il veut
envoyer du fou g5 pour interdire la
casse c'est un au roi de maximus
ouais c'est très artistique ce qui fait
mais peut-être que maxime enverra du tam
g4 échanger des dames par la suite et
après aller taper sur sur ce pion c'est
cette île budam 1,8
il veut éventuellement se recycler alors
est ce que maxime va les pousser son
effort jusqu'au bout jouer un dame de
proposer la finale
il peut aussi repartir avec le roi
angers 1-3 ce serait vraiment du foutage
de gueule proche parent d'un jeu revient
à angers 1 je suis là non je suis la
maxime qui réfléchit il doit mettre la
pression à son adversaire il peut aussi
jouer un petit coup comme dame g4 l'air
de rien qui touche un peu la tour qui
touche un peu h 4 qui touche un peu des
quatre tours à huit jouer au c'est malin
ça et veut tout reprendre dame prend
france et 7 et dames un échec maxime qui
va peut-être devoir reculer avec le fou
en c1 pour colmater la première rangée
dont il prend ses sept
et maintenant l'ordinateur donne un
avantage décisif à son adversaire
mais c'est loin d'être fait le roi qui
repart en eau de haut le coup gagnant
ici c'est roy h 6 pour les noirs et
maxime et pour jouer trois fois à cinq
et qu'ils m'acceptent aurait
probablement plus de coûts pour défendre
mais ça c'est très dur à jouer on va
voir si c'est par enough le trouveront
ils le trouvent pas et maintenant c'est
maxime qui est gagnant vous prend des
six qui par daems et 3 il va décaler le
fouet et poussé le fou qui revient au f4
les amis et le pion des qui est passé
maxime qui va y aller le maul qui par
les amis la dame en ga ne fait rien et
le pion qui n'est plus qu'à quelques
encablures ses pions qui parents des six
qui part en dix-sept il a mis la marche
avant et c'est la mobylette qui par le
fou qui va venir aux dessins qu'il est
inarrêtable ce pion des et maxime qui va
aller la chercher il va les lui faire
mal aux bulgares le bulgare en sueur les
amis maxime qui lui fait très très mal
le fou qui va venir angers 5 et il va
pas pouvoir l'arrêter il va pas pouvoir
l'arrêter le frérot damas cinq dames
proches quatre échecs font preuve si
c'est des huit dames ça paraissait le
punto c'est le poteau deux fois et demie
pour le français les amis abandon côté
bulgare et ça ça fait plaisir il a pris
des rixes masks maxime il allait se
chercher il est allé la chercher la
victoire il pointe au qui va au bout du
monde au bout du monde il nous envoie
deux points et demi les amis c'est ça
qu'on veut voir c'est ça qu'on veut voir
le roi qui est parti en d 1 kg est
revenu en e2 il lui a fait mal le
français il lui a fait mal ça c'est les
victoires qu'on veut voir on va aller
voir ce qui s'est passé côte alireza
on va voir ce qui s'est passé sur les
autres sur les autres partis c'est un
karl scène ça joue encore
donne l'impression encore joué en tout
cas
mais ça sue côté carl scène
non ça suis pas du tout en fait
à tous au top qui a perdu contre denis
ce cadre itx un cadre ich déborde mitch
au c'est joli ça
de nice quadrillé en fait on l'appelle
de nice kadri tx débordements déborder
board débordements dietsch quoi
ces cadrages débordements le frérot
1 à camurac a gagné streamer américain
qui sera la
base ada à je vous souvent sur une
chaise comme il l'a pas il a perdu
compte qu pas rasé
caruana qui a perdu caruana en sueur
hyper table 30 sassus
alireza je le cherche mais il est trop
loin au classement
mais joue contre eux
zanatta
au blanc
il ya peut-être faire nul 1 1 des buts
on a vraiment difficile pour ali reza
qui pourrait se retrouver à
1 sur 3
décevant pour le moment sur sur ces
tournants alireza
c'est pas nul théorique rebonds dont on
peut la jouer quand même un cheese ode
alireza roues et qui s'en fou peut-être
un peu aussi un
décevant il ya pas perdre y en aura
d'affaires 20e ce n'est pas décevant
qu'un
très bon tournoi d'ali reza qui finit
20e du championnat du monde de rapides
il a vraiment fait un gros tournoi
sur la ardres non on en arrive à faire
nul à ça c'est nul
ça c'est drôle
très très très belle nul de fil rouge à
contre pavel xano retape pavel qui joue
à domicile en pologne il est vraiment
vraiment très fort
surtout aux blancs
après ali reza il doit plus se
concentrer sur les candidats oui
exactement mais on a quand même le droit
de dire que c'est décevant après il
allait jouer objectifs qui soient est un
essai plus important pour lui les
candidats mais ça reste un tournoi
décevant quoi qu'il en soit
le public a fait la différence au iphone
jouer sur un échiquier à domicile c'est
pas du tout les mêmes dimensions
du coup les favoris l'ont fait quoi
magnus il a trois sur trois
griche aucune nul
ce n'est pas gris chouchoute à stefciu
christiane ce n
est pas pour ajouter dans la tête
c'était doux dingues à rafa a perdu
contre sara nassara n'a dangereux
on va attendre la prochaine on a ça
démarre dans 18 minutes enfin est en
gros c'est 12 minutes de jeu 18 minutes
de pause c'est pour être bien sûr pour
bien souffler
c'est pour être bien sûr
ça veut dire
ouais c'est pour les joueurs c'est pas
super agréable où es tu as tu préférais
en fait dans un moment ils jouaient
toutes les 20 minutes il enchaîné cinq
parties et après il faisait une pause un
peu plus longue du coup en fait tu joué
20 minutes tu joues et tu as tu joué
pendant douze minutes le temps de se
rasseoir et où donc c'était bien donc tu
jouer toutes les 20 minutes comme ça et
peut-être après cinq ou six parties
avaient une petite pause d'une demi
heure et après tu reprenaient leur
rythme
ce qu'ils faisaient avant
ce qu'on faisait avant
préparez la chicha way maxime qui donne
accès d'avoir la chicha
se trompe son ennui tu parles plus
supporter de nouvelles que tu rouge a
expliqué mille fois maxime j'ai fait
noël avec lui c'est un ami en fait
donc c'est pas je passe supporters quand
je regarde maxime le regard d'un ami
c'est complètement différent
après je sais pas si vous avez vous
comprenez le concept de l'amitié c'est
peut-être difficile
mais c'est un concept
c'est un concept
s'est pas totalement objectif festival
mais quitte de victimes demandent d'être
objective on va de personnes
objectif de quoi en fait
objectivement est-ce que regarder partie
d'échecs est intéressant je ne veux pas
me prononcer je suis objectif
je ne prononcerai su plus aucun sujet
objectivement je n'ai pas d'avis
à ses objectifs mais je veux des coups
de mer tu le dis oui au fait c'est juste
les gens qui jean-michel jalousie lien
comme maxime joue bien il joue bien
quand tu joues mal hein
non mais c'est vrai que sur tf1 ils sont
pas du tout objectif aussi quand ils
suivent les matchs de l'équipe de france
en coupe du monde j'ai remarqué que
souvent ils étaient pour l'équipe de
france ça c'est gros manque
d'objectivité en fait
c'est vrai que le frère d'ali reza est
plus pur pourra lire et zag pour mvl
j'ai remarqué aussi assez bizarre 0
objectivité
un essai qui avait tout est pareil pour
l'acaa corp aussi ouais ouais non c'est
un manque d'objectivité 1 c'est comme ça
en fait ce délire d'objectivité c'est
assez bizarre parce que en fait
quand tu commentes un truc c'est
tellement difficile d'être objectif un
même objectif ça veut dire quoi au final
je sais même pas ce que ça veut dire
l'objectivité mais c'est un truc qui est
assez fou pour moi j'arrive pas 3
comprendre ce que c'est
commenter demain objectif c'est
tellement dur enfin du coup tu sais trés
robotique en fait tu peux pas dire grand
chose puisque façon quoi que tu dises ça
va être sous tendu par un point de vue
du coût pour du vin dans la vie je peux
comprendre ce que ça veut dire mais dans
du commentaire sportif je n'arrive pas à
comprendre ça veut dire commenté de
manière objective
sens prêt
es tu as forcément un préjugés liés
attendre quand tu commandes des échecs a
forcément des positions où tu as un
billet tu préfère un joueur un autre
joueur une position une ouverture
en fait est fondamentalement pas
objectif quand les humains
pas des goûts des préférences est
obligatoire en fait tu peux pas en fait
genre moi c'est une position où les
blancs vont avoir enfin je sais pas si
tu as du dynamisme contre un pion quoi
je vais forcément préféré le joueur qui
est dynamique parce que c'est ma manière
de jouer donc du coup on fait
comment objectivement vraiment analyser
une position tu fais c'est forcément par
ta culture et chicken tes goûts je sais
même pas comment ça peut se faire en
fait
forcément ton point de vue un moment
donné il est forcément subjectif
ah ouais après il ya subjectif et dire
les terres mais comme dit quelqu'un en
chat non les termes ici sont toujours
rien un des endroits on dit le plus les
termes en vrai
les termes sont quand même très souvent
dit
les termes sont toujours dit
je me sens ici même pour critiquer de
chasse comme ah bah oui enfin quand
t'arrives pas à voir les coûts les
termes sont duty va les termes sont
toujours dit en fait
en 15
un calme
le commentaire sportif l'objectivité
s'est donné provoque une émotion sur les
adversaires d'un match mal le fait qu'on
puisse avoir dans la tête une certaine
préférence pour l'un d'entre eux en bref
les utiliser dans le commentaire sportif
ne le fait pas quelque chose d'honnête
vois ça je sais pas mais en fait
face est difficile de regarder du sport
quand le résultat de n'importe pas en
fait
c'est tellement difficile enfin moi je
regarde jamais aucun sport si je suis
pas pour une équipe rarement sauf le
rugby je peux mais rarement
je suis trop émotif façon pour ça j'ai
trop d'émotions
ce
que je disais tu peux mais en général
c'est plus marrant de supporter
quelqu'un quand même
c'est quand même plus intéressant
pour moi je regarde beaucoup plus les
matches quand je supporte une équipe ou
un joueur d'échecs j'ai beaucoup plus
facilement regarder une partie de mvl
contre carl scène que de
de n'importe qui d'autre en fait parce
que ça m'intéresse de voir si maxime va
gagner
etc ça en fait
ok
t
il sans trop le côté [ __ ] qui remonte
en tout cas
sympa ce début de tour à de maximy
commence bien tu pas qu'il joue à la
prochaine s'il a déjà les appariements
bachelor de la pro d2 je m'en fiche qui
joue j'ai aucune préférence juste ça
joue quoi bah oui moi aussi je regarde
la pro d2 comme ça mais c'est oui
j'espère un beau match ou un beau truc
oui je peux aussi mais c'est plus
marrant quand c'est ton équipe qui joue
tu vois un france angleterre
ouais tu vois c'est des fois c'est même
pas que quand ton équipe joue la france
angleterre tu as quand même un peu envie
de gagner quoi
comme ce à quoi
un crunch ça fait toujours plaisir
une préférence pour tel ou tel
équipement souvent c'est le
sait le jeu et
le professionnalisme du métier te
demande de l'objectivité mais en fait je
n'arrive pas à comprendre qu'ils qui
décrète que un commentateur sportif doit
être objectif en fait le conseil du
métier mai
xinhua le professionnalisme du métier
c'est qu'il ya des gens qui suivent et
qui a envie de regarder avec toi
si c'est pour que personne regarde
et tout le monde se disent que le sport
que tu que tu commentes il fait vivre
aucune émission et émotion il est chiant
pour le professionnalisme de de
commenter des échecs c'est de faire ce
intéresser les gens aux échecs en fait
et après comment tu le fais ça c'est ton
problème
mais pour moi l'objectif il est que les
gens ils partagent la même passion coin
en fait
en soi
c'est comme ça mais en plus maxime c'est
un gars qui est tellement gentil tu vas
au delà du fait qu'il soit français ou
quoi c'est tellement une crème c'est
tellement un mec bien en fait moi qui le
connais vraiment perso
comment tu peux ne pas être pour maxime
en fait
c'est maxime c'est vraiment
vraiment quelqu'un d'exceptionnel quoi
après comme je dis moi je le connais
donc je m'en rend d'autant plus content
mais c'est quelqu'un doit forcément
envie qu'ils réussissent en fait
bon j'espère qu'on va les parties sans
bug
j'ai pas qui on va voir sur la caméra on
n'aura pas maxime
qui reviennent dans les trois premières
tables en fête
caruana ça se voit que j'aime bien
réussi quand on commente je le connais
pas perso mais après c'est peut-être le
côté [ __ ] que je ressens mais tu vas
caruana c'est un joueur que j'apprécie
après
un
ton âme 40 ans mais caruana c'est un
gars aussi tu as un joueur que j'aime
beaucoup quoi
il a un beau style il fait des belles
parties tu sens qu'il donne toujours
100%
non c'est beau joueur
puisque m il ya des joueurs j'ai mon
envie qui gagne mais
bon ça commence et savard buggé je pense
là semble
pas trop ça l'a
assise c'est bon on va l'avoir
maxime au noir
j'aurais abandonné le tournoi
classe
on va les avoir les horloges
et la bonté il fait un mauvais début de
ton il a peut-être avant de tourner ça
m'étonnerait mais bon peut-être 1
on n'a pas la cas main pour avoir maxime
on va bientôt la voir maxime cam il va
remonter
il est peut-être malades bas si les
malades y aurait peut-être mieux fallu
une juste pas finir et pas contaminer
tout le monde quoi
à part un magnifique
donc ça va partir les amis on va voir
les coûts qui vont arriver et cavaliers
f3 pour visite ils jouent tous cavaliers
r3 maxi maxime qui avaient fait nul
assez facilement dans le rapide contre
le joueur indien le prince du gange
comme on l'appelle vie dit le prince et
et maxime donc il va jouer un gambit
dame alors il joue en fait des dégâts en
bide à m'accepter et oui il m'avait
prévenu d'une surprise maxime pour ce
tournoi et on va on va voir comment il
s'en sort donc le souvent ça joue des
pions isoler les noirs vont prendre en
d4 et les blancs pour jouer davantage
vont accepter de d'isoler leurs pions en
d4 mais pour jouer sur l'activité et le
contrôle du centre mais maxime lui n'a
pas pris en d4 et du coup ces visites
qui vient prendre ans et sinko pour
jouer avec b4 et jouer sur une position
un tout petit peu plus agréable avec un
léger avantage de développement côté est
côté indien maxime qui va venir jouer
maintenant le petit roy qui va envoyer
un pion b5 un fou en bessette ça reste
quand même solide je pense que maxime
dans cette quatrième partie au noir une
nulle lui convient tout à fait visite
c'est un glisseur extrêmement
dangereux bessines co qui est parti
alors maintenant visite qui hésitent à
mettre le fou sur la diagonale on a 2 ou
en d3 mais en d3 il est mieux placé
visite qui va tenter d'attaquer un les
droits regarder les fous son braquet et
non ils jouent dames 2 il va tenter de
pousser à 4 et de mettre la pression
peut être aller le roy maxime peut quand
même faire petit rock ici replacer son
fou en d6 en gros on va avoir une
position symétrique avec un ou deux ans
de plus pour le joueur indien le joueur
indien qui placent maintenant sa tour en
d1 qui veut interdire food et si ces
dames 7 justement sur food est si sûre
et fouquerolles cet échec et on comptait
6 maxime qui va devoir trouver un bon
coup ici ce coût pourrait être d'un v8
ou dams et 7 pour venir mettre le fou en
d6 quand même mais la tour va venir en
c1 donc on va décaler d'abord la tour on
sait 8 puis mettre la dame en b vite
puis le fou en d6 maxime qui tentent de
s'organiser
c'est une position vraiment
assez égal mais plus agréable à jouer
aux blancs bien évidemment puisque ben
on a on a des temps plus si tout
bêtement donc h3 qu'ils aient joué ça
permet d'anticiper un peu fou des 6es la
pression sur h demain sim qui joue la
tour en des 8 il va après à les cacher
sa dame en b 8 et peut-être même aller
se glisser jusqu'en à 8 pour aller taper
le long de la grande diagonale en
batterie on s'attend à voir un tour à
ses seins d'une minute à l'autre côté
indien mais de toute façon comme maxime
veut jouer d'un bep 8 il ne s'empresse
pas simplement il a plu beaucoup de
plans il peut aussi tenter un carré libé
trois cavaliers décathlon email à tours
en c1
maxime qui va aller se cacher en b 8 et
il va aller se diriger vers la case à
huit mains non peut-être que visite s'il
est ambitieux va tenter le coup et
quatre pour faire une prise du centre
non il envoie le quart aller en b3 et
touche pas vraiment la casse et 5 maxime
va probablement partir pour une
liquidation totale et se diriger vers
une petite nul son adversaire ne tente
pas grand chose pour le moment dans
cette partie et maxime n'a aucun intérêt
à prendre des risques et se suicider ici
il va remettre la tour ans et 8 échanger
les tours le long de la colonne c
est tranquillement se diriger vers une
nullement il tente fou prend f3 maxime
qui allume la première mèche dans cette
partie d'un f3 camaïeu 5e' force ou
prendre 5 d'en prendre 5 maxi ne veut
pas de la nulle contrainte elle comme
vie dit il ne veut pas de là nul mais il
prend des vrais risques ici ça peut être
un peu dangereux ça peut être un peu
dangereux puisque maintenant le cavalier
menace d'arriver en c6 de faire une
fourchette
maxime qui va devoir jouer un coup comme
d'amd 5 et un petit peu souffrir
il joue un il joue le gain food & cie ce
qui est excessif damage deux échecs
maxime allais il prend les risques il
prend ses responsabilités dans ce
tournoi
le fou qui vient en d6
et il menace d'un match 2
/ g iii il va il va peut-être envoyé du
hasch sinko h quattro
on va vous voir ce que fait visite
maintenant la partie n'est pas très
endiablé mais elle peut être dangereuse
g3 e-menaces cavalli c6 de nouveaux
d'amd 5 propose les changes des dames et
la tour va rentrer en c6 maxime
légèrement moins bien il veut cavaliers
c7 et tout blindés
il aurait peut-être mieux fallu être un
pleutre éclairé à la ba qui plutôt que
de prendre autant autant de risques le
fou qui vient à eux quatre il veut
prendre en d5 ou ramener le fou en
décembre et cette attention ça devient
vraiment très dangereux ici pour maxime
qui est proche de perdre en réalité au
ce serait
un coup de tonnerre pour le joueur
français que de perdre contre visite
aussi tôt dans le tournoi il s'est
exposé un maxima aller chercher la
victoire ça lui a porté chance contre
chez paris 9 à la ronde précédente mais
contre un joueur du calibre de deux
visites santos gujrat i c'était
peut-être un petit peu trop optimistes à
lille va falloir mettre une petite
poignée de barbelés maintenant il faut
un petit mur de barbelés dans le chat
pour aider maxime à tenir parce que se
font à eux quatre ils fait mal hein les
pions vont être touchés par derrière et
maxime n'arrive pas à toucher les pions
adverse il a toujours ses petit temps de
retard
cavalli c7 ça semble être le coup mais
là le fou va arriver en baissse est là
la tour en c6
est sale une pluie de barbelés peut
aider à sauver maxime ici on va voir ce
que ce que décide visite ya peut-être
aussi cavalli c6 pour aller toucher des
cases on va voir on va voir c'est
difficile de se prononcer mais en tout
cas maxime va avoir fort à faire pour
sauver le devis points qui avale et c6
qui est jouée
sur tour des 7 vallées des huit tours
des huit tours c'est ça il aura pas à
tour c'est ici sur un ton plan b 8 tours
prend des six est peut-être contient
assez difficile on va espérer car elle
est bénie tour des beatles et cissé et
répète non ils jouent autour des 1 le
joueur le joueur indien il veut jouer
sur le clouage
maxime qui va devoir partir pour du roi
est lui 3e set pour le monde cavaliers
c7 colmate bien quand même hein
c'est
c'est un petit peu du scotch sur un lit
gonflables une petite rustine ce
cavalier c7 le lit gonflable qui a été
détruit par le chien mais le cavalier c7
qui pour le mans couche bouchât les
trous et fab qui va pouvoir dormir
dessus en tout cas on espère l'idée de
cavalia set c'était d'interdire roy e
set à cause de cavale et ses huit échecs
donc maxime qui joue là la tour en des
8es foulées cette maxime qui met le fou
ici en 7 et tour c est maintenant au
sila en train de traquer maxime food et
6 cavale et ses huit il passe par
derrière vie dit il est en train de le
prendre par derrière et ça fait mal
cavale et ses huit peut-être qu'à
rallier des cinq encore un peu
miraculeux il fait tour c'est 6 maxime
qui est très très mal mais la rustine
qui tient encore tourbe et 800 francs
des six temps prend bessette
ça fait mal ça fait mal pour maxime et
il est mieux autant une minute contredit
seconde il va falloir faire craquer le
joueur indien pour maxim roy u8 maxime
qui doit tenter des pièges vous prend à
6 ouais mais là il ya les deux pions qui
tombe arriver peut-être qu'elle prend
assisteront à six tours à 8 on prend des
six tours prend et tour des 3 et tenir
sa non il fait il fait roi 17 il veut
quoi foulée cinq accueils prend b5
surtout bessette la tourbe et 8
peut-être tombé huit tombes et six
cavaliers des cinq hoya pouces et six
échecs qui fait mal
maxime qui est complètement foutu
à l'efo qui la sauve celle là
elle est difficile le prince du gange
qui est en train de faire mal qui est
des cinq ans avait pris ses huit vous
prendrez 8 qui est tombé 5 je vois mal
comment maxime peut la sauver
cavalier b6 ça fait deux pions moins
maintenant deux pions passé attention
fuhe 5
il peut même pas rentrer en c3 a eu un
très mauvaise partie de la part de
maxime
alors qu'elle irait à fiuggi a déjà jeté
l éponge
il ne peut rien faire ici il est
complètement fou tu
as est terrible c'est terrible parce que
parce qu'ils attention les fous de
couleurs opposées peut-être
est-ce qui peut sauver sa
les deux pions pas scellier ont l'air de
faire mal
non il pourra pas les arrêter
ouais ça va pas le faire pour maxime
ça ne va pas faire il a abandonné il
jette l'épongé deux ennemis sur quatre
parties difficiles
on va aller voir ce qui se passe du côté
des autres favoris
c'est décevant
pas au niveau maximum ce début de
tournoi
alors que magnus caracole en tête il va
encore la gagner il va être à quatre sur
quatre
terrible
s'ils me questionne un peu la force et
qui a perdu bon il a encore le temps de
remonter il ya beaucoup de monde
maxime pas aussi tranchant qu'il a été à
une époque
en blitz
bartosz chef tchenko
bartosz qui gagne
la caméra tiens
tiens murat
au blanc qui va faire annuler
les filles auront finalement qui joue
je vais essayer de le trouver
jouer contre caen tort il a gagné firent
où il remonte un petit peu alors il va
se retrouver à deux points
allez il peut remonter
il peut remonter alireza s'est passé pas
rédhibitoire il ya vingt-trois partie 2
sur 4 2 me sur 4 ça se remonte à 1 faut
juste
enchaîné là c'est dommage pour maxime
parce que hyper queuille
y perd en voulant peut-être trop en
faire
en plus ça aurait été sa aurait pu être
bon mais c'est pas bien passé
ces pastilles passer par en tête qu'il a
pensé qu'il était mieux
difficile à dire un
état vraiment le temps de remonter un
bon maxime qui est en train de maximois
magnus qui est déjà en train de
s'envoler
avec quatre points sur quatre mais bon
c'est juste dommage on aurait pu
recoller quoi
on aurait pu recoller
et revenir à la cam
mais maxime on le sent moins tranchant à
un blitz qu'à une époque un
jeune parti akel heures à 17 heures
je
de man is murder en regardant faire ça
nul avec les blancs mode full trop loin
une vidéo aussi que j'ai vu toréer ya
pas longtemps magnus qui fait des gros
gwada andrew de tang
exceptionnel je me permettrai pas de le
refaire en live mais il fait des gros
add
ils insultent plus ou moins quoi
s'extraire extraordinaire en lui faisant
des gros watts quoi c'est beau
c'est magnifique
oui c'est extraordinaire
des oueds en buvant de la bière ouais
c'est extraordinaire
sera ordinaire
en écoutant du rap ouais ouais ça c'est
assez marrant
je sais pas si le week end il va tirer à
l'armé à feu ou genre de truc pour pour
se chauffer
c'est magnifique
c'est extraordinaire
alors tu veux trouver sur youtube
extraordinaire
je pensais que je faisais un peu trash
talk quand je jouais mais en fait c'est
rien à côté de man u ça c'est terrible
mais massa et des meilleurs
il est même plus vulgaire quoi s'était
elle-même en vulgarité il me dépasse
comme quoi
même à ça y est les meilleurs
il était totalement bout ouais c'est
magnifique
mouais
le chat rapidement mais juste
j'économise aussi ma voix
jojo forfait non pas du tout on sait
dans le chatt
sarraute et importe quoi ça m'étonnait
aussi mais bon après
on oublie pas les pubs tiens c'est nous
c'est une bonne chose ça le bas rend fou
c'est une belle idée
genre
ma nièce ou vodka je crois que vlad
tient beaucoup mieux hein
je crois que manu ça vraiment aucune
chance je crois qu'il a assez vite
bourré en vrai
en vrai je crois qu'il a assez vite
rebbouh
comparer un vlad qui tient coi
même moi je pense que je tiens beaucoup
mieux en fait je tiens pas mal mais
ça fait trop longtemps que je bois plus
du tout donc difficile à dire
mais c'est sûr que contre la ville a
aucune chance
on
bruce wave là d'après c'est pas le plus
solide un tu prends un karpatchev
ne va pas faire long feu un
karpatchev il a du coffre
un stream une insulte et les gens il y
avait un mec qui disait qu'il avait pris
juste une bière mais je pense c'est vrai
en plus
ce que généralement situe stream bourré
tu le fais pas
en fait tu vas pas stream bien tu sais
que c'est pas un bon exemple de le faire
donc tu vas tu vas pas bourrer la gueule
avant de stream et c'est complètement
débile s'est passé pas une bonne chose
de faire ça donc pour que ça arrive faut
vraiment être bourré très rapidement
jo attia ça m'est arrivé de stream et en
ayant bu un verre de vin ou un truc
comme ça ça va rien me faire mais genre
vraiment rien du tout
même deux verres de vin ne vont rien
faire
mais ça excite et bourré après une bière
ouais c'est ça paraît assez logique en
fait
taille du verre
ouais bon après un verre de vin normal
mais ça fait rien en fait
mais c'est vrai que du coup ça corrobore
un peu le ce que disait le gars derrière
dont le dans le stream de magnus
vous dire tu peux stream et c'est à peu
près ça va
soit c'est marrant
reprendre dans une dizaine de minutes
je crois qu'un handicap à un gem pour
qu'un match plein de 2016 comme son
équilibre et une dame peut-être et une
tour
petit point sur le classement et que je
vais même pas vraiment moi-même générant
je regarde pas le classement de ce
tournoi avant cette fronde ce qu'il ya
tellement de partie que faut laisser le
truc se décanter en fait
la rép pas grand chose à dire faut
laisser un peu des écarts se faire
la cadence mais on a en 2003 comme je
pense une tour en vrai je pense une tour
c'est quoi les points forts de vlad je
sais pas les gars poser de ces questions
ça dépend par rapport à qui par rapport
à toi tout
mais après
son niveau je sais pas assez compliqué
non mais c'est compliqué quand les
points forts il a que des points forts
en fait
alors niveau au niveau de baky de maxime
et où ils ont que des points forts
ce qu'ils font pas très bien c'est par
rapport aux autres du top mondial mais
sinon il ya que des points forts
puis bondé en plus les points forts
après cette structure de pioncer truc
vraiment très concret parfois
quoi vlad pas partie du top 10 monde va
déjà il a 25 ans tu trop
et puis après
jn de ville travaille comme souvent
4 tout comme un peu plus de monde est
incapable à son époque oui mais
aujourd'hui serait peut-être différent
c'est dur à dire
maxime par contre là voilà ce qui se
passe pour maxime c'est que et demi sur
quatre c'est pas rédhibitoire en
revanche deux ennemis sur cinq bon c'est
sûr pas rédhibitoire non plus mais tu
commences à être bien en fait il est
quasi en must win pour rester collés
groupe
dès que tu perds c'est dur là
sur cinq sera pas valu d'être à trois et
demi quand même juste à 3 sur 5 et que
magnus est déjà à 5
c'est un peu relou quoi
après tu es vraiment must win toulon qui
jouent contre anti pop inventive hd
battue a pas longtemps à 8 sur 13 comme
j'avais fait un mais il est vraiment
très fort c'est un adversaire redoutable
mainz en perdant une marque souffre il
en perdra plus qu'une ou en tout cas il
ne sera plus qu'un point il va pas faire
bien sûr 21,1 magnus
c'est possible de ne pas se faire
appareiller de gagner 0 5 ans tournoi
non ça c'est pas possible mais le quitus
à c'est que dans les tournants un peu
un peu moins
passe pas pour les tournois top niveau
avec des
des titres en jeu ça c'est pas possible
car le statu quo ouais sauf qu'il va
prendre cher 1
j'ai fait une perte de fous furieux
maxime je trouve bien un peu régressé en
blitz où les autres ont progressé bien
moins d'écart qu'avant
et fier où il joue qui
maxime qui fit way
maxime qui vieillit
s'ils ont déjà théodore ou
dangereux théodore ou en blitz en vrai
le confident peut-être les davantage
jouant beats cave en réalisant
l'avantagé maxime incroyable agust
cheater d'un commentaire très
intelligent il mériterait presque un vip
le frérot
c'est rare que dans le chatt ondes et du
pertinents
c'est très rare
mais ça a fini par arriver
quelqu'un vient d'écrire quelque chose
d'intelligent
et c'est assez rare pour être souligné
c'est magnifique
abbas et c'est quand même assez
extraordinaire
non je ne pense pas que tu as écrit des
trucs intelligents et qu'on les a pas
vus non non non non 1 quand il ya des
trucs intelligents je remarque assez
facilement je te rassure
ça ça ne t'inquiète pas
or si maxime réussi à gagner important
de saméon type of c'est un jeune c'est
pas un adversaire facile très
franchement il n'y a pas d'adversaire
facile dans ce tournoi
anti peuvent c'est un jeune et
il a été 3 me sur czech comme c'est un
bon blitzer très clairement
non avec ce message ce message était
magnifique
nouvelle game qui va partir
maxime qui va devoir
aff
ça va partir on va voir de façon sûre la
caméra toutes les parties commencent en
même temps
refuser parlement de maxime bons fous ça
dépend
y a que des joueurs forts ici donc c'est
difficile d'avoir des bons apparemment
mais
qui peuvent c'est un gars chiant mais il
faut le battre 1
nature anti parfois y'a pas longtemps a
fait deux parties on a fait 1 mais bon
après on va voir à l'esa par
là il doit être surmotivés anti pop et
c'est un vrai c'est un jeune dangereux
4,5 on va sûrement voir une espagnole
c'est chose faite maxime qu'il l'envoie
est berlinoise aller la petite finale de
la berlinoise maxime
il la joue comme dans un rêve mais il
part pas pour la finale dans cette
partie il va jouer le milieu de jeu de
la berlinoise qui joue aussi très bien
aller va falloir cliquant des quatre
places et les pièces
prendre
l'aventage du centre prendre l'espace au
centre et après éventuellement même
aller aller chercher une expansion
allèles dame
la tour qui peut revenir en deux parfois
dans ses positions c'est justement ce
qu'il fait pour décaler plus tard la
tour 1 er maxime qui joue tout re 2 il
va sûrement y avoir un coup comme
cavalier f5 ici de la part de mihail non
il mais envoie le quart alliance et
quatre cavaliers qui fait pas grand
chose à part profité de la tour qui
obstruent le le fou mais c'est vrai
qu'elle mena e-menaces rien mais sur b3
il veut repartir en b6 j'ai l'impression
et se libérer la case des 5 c'est donc
ça l'idée d'en type of
alors est-ce qu'on lui provoque oui
maxime qui provoque le cavalier et qui
envoie le plus ans et calbo il va faire
des 5 il est venu pour il veut essayer
de provoquer ces 5 et repartir en
dix-sept j'imagine
pour aller chercher du g6 où j'essaie de
cavaliers 6 ou quelque chose dans ce
style ou du tour huit cavaliers fuite et
à très solide en revanche si le fait pas
il va peut-être y avoir du fou à 3 pour
maxime suivi de cavalli c3 et une belle
prise d' espaces
on va voir ça réfléchit côté côté russe
il envoie le d5
c5 va être joué par maxime cavaliers 17
maintenant il va falloir trouver un coup
peut-être fou et 4 1 pour se développer
naturellement améliorer cac et prend ses
500 français 5 fu prend un c'est la
menace alors peut-être qu'il faut jouer
un coup comme b4 mais il y aurait dû à 5
est sûre à 3 puis on prend tu comprends
tout reprend 1 maxime en petites
difficultés
alors pas qu'ils soient moins bien mais
c'est dur à stabiliser il est peut-être
obligé de jouer four b2 mais c'est pas
genre de coups qu'on veut jouer le
fousseret mal placé c'est cette menace
qui est français 5 est vraiment pénible
il n'y a pas d'âme c'est de yahia fou
prend des 4 et tour ces 2
mai à tour ces deux peut-être mais bon
c'est un peu mou latour quitterait la
colonne maxime qui met le fou en en b2
et anti pub va probablement jouer
maintenant c'est 6 et va essayer de se
déployer avec du dams et c'est tout du
tour huit cavaliers fuite maxime qui va
échanger tous les tours maintenant
mettre la d'avancé de peut-être le
cavalier verde de f3 dont il fait
cavalier trois cavaliers c3 d'abord
pardon c6 qui consolide ce cavalier qui
est un peu bizarre sur la case c3 le
problème c'est qu'il a zéro au bond vers
l'avant regarder il est complètement
annihilés par les pions et s'y vend un
cadre de toute façon il sera bloqué par
la suite c'est pour ça avec maxime faits
d'armes des deux avec l'idée surtout
preuve de de jouer cavalier prend eux
deux et d'aller re naviguer avec le
cheval de l'autre côté de l'échiquier
c'est chose faite cavalia fuite pour
anti pof et maintenant peut-être 1 4
d-4d 5 il va falloir envoyer la marche
avant à halen allèles dame pour maxime
mais la position n'est n'est pas simple
un regard des espions des quatre qui
peut être touchée avec du cavalier e 6
ce pion c5 qui est pas super super et
les noirs qui sont très solides
maintenant le pion g6 vient de nouveau
complètement au mur et ce cavalier qui
n'arrive pas à s'exprimer dans cette
partie il n'est pas en grande forme le
carré les g3 de maxime il va allait
falloir chercher une case pour lui cette
casse ce serait au 5 mai à les deux
cases en diagonale et il faudra les
trouver un plan de type cavaliers f1 h
de f3 pour revenir aux cinq ça va être
trop long maxime qui va devoir tout
miser sur l'expansion allèles dame à
quatre baies quatre baies 5 qui va qui
va partir
son adversaire anti pauvres qui met le
cavalier en russie si bien contre
attaquer le même attaqué le pion des
quatre pour le moment défendu mais il va
y avoir un plan avec dame est fluide
dame g7 maintenant assez marlou pour
venir pousser et ferme à l'option d'un
mec 8 qui est jouée en ti peuvent qui a
les coups qu'ils allaient coup et qui va
aller chercher du d'alger cette maxime
dans le dur début de tournoi
complètement raté de la part du joueur
français pour le moment on l'a dit la
partie contre visite est importante pour
vraiment se mettre en confiance est
rentré dans cette première journée ça
n'a pas été réussie on sent maxime qui
souffre maintenant contre antibes of un
joueur dangereux aller le cavalier qui
retrouve là la casse c'est un qui va les
chercher p3 et peut-être même à 5 mais
ce sera annihilé là encore par un fou
ces huit lecavalier qui ne trouvent pas
de travail pour le moment en tout cas
ils se replacent il essaye de se battre
ils essayent de résister de prouver
qu'ils existent et et le les pions
blancs qui vont peut-être partir à
quatre baies 5 quand même tôt ou tard
pour aller chercher du contre je pour
maxime on voit bien que les noirs ont
une pression énorme sur ce pion des
quatre qui vont pouvoir cibler fortement
et maxime il n'arrive pas à se
dépatouiller de ça pour le moment allez
on va espérer qu'ils trouvent les coups
qu'ils trouvent les coûts pour faire
tourner la position en sa faveur
allez c'est anti peuvent maintenant de
réfléchir
il n'a pas les couilles peut-être
cavaliers detroit pour maxime un jour
pour cavaliers 5 mais c'est tellement
dur de passer
il ya la casse des quatre
qui fait mal ce fut un des quatre qui
fait mal mon petit peuple à qui est en
train de bloquer il n'a pas le plan il
n'a pas la réf le joueur russe je vais
aller vérifier que ce soit pas une
erreur de retransmission oh que non la
retransmission à allaire a l'air de
fonctionner sans type of key tanks et
c'est peut-être là la chance de maxime
fou j'estime qu'au jouer alors il va s
qui va aller chercher le cavalier c'est
un j'ai envie de dire merci monsieur 1
on va pouvoir aller jouer les cases
noires voilà il a échangé c'est une
énorme erreur stratégique à mon avis
dans type of qui donne toutes les cases
noires et maintenant maxime va pouvoir
jouer à quatre baies 5 et peut-être un
jour x 5 fou fou c'est cette fois au
cinquième venir jouer les cases noires
ça y est maxime qui passe l'accélérateur
il va avoir du dames c'est cette
maintenant pour entrer anti-pape en
train de se faire pénétrer la part
devant cette fois-ci par devant par
l'avant via la casse c'est cette qui qui
brille mais la dame qui va aller en
hausse 1 quand ils peuvent qui va
essayer de résister avec dame g7 quand
même échangé les dames et jouer cette
finale qui est peut-être nul mais
maintenant c'est maxime 1 qui met la
pression sur damas gsm si vos dames
cette maxime est rentré sur la septième
rangée il joue deux faces maxime damas
dans des huit dames cinq dames c'est
cette arrivée d'un f 6 des 8 très
pleutre mais marlou quand même côté
russe maxim qui va devoir trouver les
coûts maintenant est ce qu'ils jouent
dame f6 dam des huit dames prend des 8es
la finale peut-être il va falloir après
monter le roi et réussir à la percée
c'est ce qu'est en train de ferme c'est
ce que maxime est en train de faire
absolument
aller il va falloir il va falloir
augmenter la position fait remonter la
position comme comme disent les russes
f3 gk3 f2 roi g3 et trouver une porte
d'entrée mais ça va être compliqué parce
que les noirs vont blindés les quinze
ans avec le cavalier si on vient
échanger le fou contre le cavalier on
aura une position à [ __ ] couleurs
opposées qui sera nul il semble que
maxime n'est pas de porte d'entrée ici
mais plus de dix secondes pour anti
peuvent s'il va chercher des pièges
maxime il va chercher à faire travailler
son roi maintenant
donc
le fou qui va peut-être venir en offrant
des six chez 4h 4 qui peut qui peut
aussi partir pour prendre de l'espace et
le roi qui va peut-être aller se
chercher un chemin via à 5 regardez moi
cette manoeuvre qui peut arriver
cavaliers c'est de bien jouer sur food
et 3 on est d'accord d'échangé les
pièces côté noir mais maxime qui est en
train de le travailler au corps là haut
il en train de vouloir rentrer dans la
position adverse et peut-être allait se
diriger jusqu'en b8 avec le roi blanc
c'est le plan de maxime en tout cas il
va travailler ça il va ramener le fou un
f4 le fou ou 3 il va y va le mettre ici
pour consolider et il va partir il va
partir maxime avec le roi il s'approche
il s'approche il s'approche mais anti
pop en train de contrer et maxime qui va
peut-être passer en f4 non il fait h4
qui a valu au cices peut-être qu'il veut
du g4 pour provoquer les changes de du
curage contre le pion à compte le pion f
a maintenant f5 et jouer ça y est tout
et sur tout et sur case blanche et
maintenant maxime va peut-être envoyé
alors soit roi des trois-rois qu'à 3,5
mais aussi roi des deux rois ou trois
rois f4 de quel côté il va rentrer allez
y par côté et parallèles dame maxime qui
est en train de partir à la dame qui va
jouer avec le fouet f4 leroy b 6 ans a
l'air d'être quasi gagnant non pour
maxime ça a l'air de faire très mal le
roi qui est en train de rentrer maxime
qui fait le taf n'aura pas droit à ses
sept tours à b 8 pour colmater le roi
qui va aller jusqu'en b6 il vient
s'enfoncer dans les lignes ennemies
maxime
allais il faut faire le taf maintenant
avec food et 3 et g4 à l'échangé les
pions et à les envoyer le pion h à adam
l'ailier de maximy fait il faut faire
chanter la balle allait maintenant il
faut aller faire chanter les banales
elle les ailiers qui vont faire le
boulot on attaque à l'oeil gauche à la
droite et maintenant c'est le cadrage
débordement qui arrive ça échange est ce
qu'il ya des exemples peut-être anti
peuvent y aura encore du cavaliere fuite
maxime va devoir trouver un bon coup ici
mais on est à deux doigts de gagner un
fouet f3 fouet 8 il va faire quoi il va
faire b5 il affaiblit le pion des 5
maxime à bab il n'y a pas de cb y'a pas
de carte bancaire maintenant pour anti
pop qui auraient loupé rang des saints
qui fait cavalier fuite il veut
cavaliers 17 quand même c'est bien joué
il veut qui a aidé cet échec maxime qui
a obligé de repartir avec le roi le fou
qui va venir angers katzav a joué un
petit clouage ici il va falloir trouver
là là la porte d'entrée la serrure noir
est solide mais les fous font mal le
foin f4 qui bloque le fou angers 4 leroy
qui veut rentrer en dix-sept fois f7 il
tient encore pour le moment mais on est
proches de zhouqu sanguin côté côté noir
le bleu roi qui vient à 6 le roi et le
fou qui vient à eux ça en a cinq qui va
vouloir maintenant jouer fuhe deux fois
six matt aut c'est magnifique ce qu'est
en train de faire maxime c'est un
orfèvre les amis le schéma de maths est
en place non il n'a pas fait fou et je
suis assez étonné ça paraissait
tellement fort idcg à l'euro c'est
complètement raté
maxime karaté faut deux fois ci c'est
plus gagnant pour maxime
c'est plus gagnant le roi maintenant à
trouver la casse b cette
maxime qui s'est complètement trompé il
a raté m'attend de maxime
il ya peut-être fou et kébé vite
possible
en tout cas il a il a raté quelque chose
et maintenant les noirs se sont
réorganisés c'est terrible c'est
terrible les avis et maintenant les
noirs qui vont peut-être même jouer le
gain
maxime qui s'est raté aller il faut
quand même aller la chercher celle là il
n'y a pas le choix il faut gagner s'ils
gagnent pas cette partie ce serait une
terrible désillusion parce que la
position il allait quasiment gagnante il
en gagne 90 % des positions comme celle
là mais aujourd'hui il est dans le dur
il a du mal et le roi qui n'a pas de
casque d'entrée un lecavalier qui est
impérial
maxime qui va devoir tenter non il n'a
rien à tenter en fait le cavalier couvre
tout il peut pas la gagner c'est
incroyable
y'avait pas tout à fait m'a tant donné
peut-être kébé 8 on reviendra dessus
après
mais maxime n'a pas de case d'entrer ici
il remet le foin à 4 leroy qui vient
mérité des huit ça navigue
rien à tenter à c'est terrible d'avoir
raté ça
c'est terrible maxime nous a habitué à
gagner un
avec quasi 100% ce genre de position
ouais c'est terrible il est en train de
ramener son revers à 5 il va tenter
peut-être de mettre un fou à 6 pouces et
8 dont tu as you avec les pièces ne
bouge pas c'est jusque antipop joue
cavalier des huit cavaliers aux 6 maxime
qui va aller tenter de faire quelque
chose là-bas sur sur cette aile roi
ouais c'est terrible désillusion encore
ouais c'est difficile
une nouvelle fois un maxime qui joue
bien mais le niveau d'exigence
est élevé parce que maxime est un des
tout meilleurs joueurs du monde et on
attend de lui la perfection à ffu prend
ici s'il accepte de faire un nul
malheureusement il va peut-être tenté un
dernier piège de mettre le ranger 5
et de fer h5 même pas
maxime qui rate cette position c'est
incroyable
je sais pas ce qu'était le gard le 15
c'était pas x 2 je pensais qu'il voulait
x 2 mai
cavaliers b8 semblait peut-être
défendrait
j'ai pas comme on leur dit gagner ça il
faisait qu il faisait quoi fou des deux
rois c'est cette fois f4
croatie 8
b 1
il faut à 4 5 il a raté
sur jackie a gagné ouais donc il revient
à trois points sur cinq
dommage pour maxima il avait tellement
la position
firo jack est de retour
qui a battu teodoro inquiétez pas un
joueur facile
et le saumon a perdu est
donc qui restent à quatre points mais
qui jouera encore tableau 1 ne vous
inquiétez pas
car celle qui a perdu contre sochaux
vannes aux
penalties il lui a fait mal trente deux
coups
et bhl
bhl
bon 3 sur 5 ses pas rédhibitoire 1
victoire aurait été mieux quand même
bon après
finira genre 8 sur 11 c'est très bien
donc s'ils font 5 sur 6 à partir de là
les français ils seront bien dans le
tournoi
on se sent moins moins fringant maxime à
une époque ce genre de position
il est gagné 1
il est gagné il a moins de
ça fuse - quoi
oui non c'est sûr ils jouent bien en ti
peuvent c'est un bon buteur et il défend
bien
juste maxime nous a habitué à mieux 1
c'est comme un musée c'est qu'on
s'attend à l'exception
des jouets à des coûts exceptionnels
quand on suit maxime
un
que maxime soit c'est pour les échecs
non mais
c'est dur de rester à haut niveau 1
pendant longtemps
c'est vraiment dur hein
c'est vraiment très difficile de rester
au top top
drake sur le vitrail doit pas être très
bien là on l'a pas trop vu le l'ouzbek
on n'a pas le bonus bec
il a vraiment bien joué ça tu auras fier
incroyable
c'est un autre performant on verra ça va
loin
atlan
ça rejoint
toutes les demi-heures en fait donc
c'est assez facile là pour pour la peine
il n'y a pas de retard
maxime à 3 sur 5 donc il est bien
ça va je sors commencé à gagner c'est
plus les coûts qui inquiète
c'est plus les coûts qui inquiète
les coups font peur
fm 10e mariage est un cheval monde
d'oubli de souillac ans il s'appelle
j'ai plus son nom
un gars contre qui jouissent souvent
sur une chaise comme qui était dans les
premiers
c'était quoi déjà son nom à un gamin de
base et f
et
il avait il avait bien joué pendant
longtemps
garman il était dans les premiers
étaient vraiment dans les premières
places
le petit gars manou
bons joueurs germann
sa trace et participe à la course
candidats non pas du tout
coc une pointure annick neff sinndar
rich media chris64 mais il doit y avoir
car le sann aussi a4
fabriqué ni un 5-0 à garat noël germann
ça devient un peu le client dernièrement
j'allais me refais je fais de l'eau
mais de retour les gars
bischheimois peut-être à wil michaud
ambulants qui peut se présenter
il ya de la miche ambulante qui peut
passer 1
original si ça n'était pas content hop
hop hop hop hop hop ça dégage
est pas content alt f4 s'appuie sur alt
sur ton clavier en même temps sur f4 tu
vas voir ça va t'aider ça va faire du
bien
c'est c'est une bonne solution si t'es
pas content si tu kiffes apte écoute ap
un frère
illias on a regardé fil rouge à non-stop
nom avait bon c'est
encore un gars tu kiffes à técou tape et
puis c'est tout en fait
tu peux répondre sur un grand témoin je
suis je t'ai répondu jargon été aussi
pas de touches sur ton clavier qui vont
t'aider frère
au
coeur
6 apparemment c'est quoi carlson fait
d'os ou harry krishna camurat way
commencé à avoir des chocs et rouge à
english ses shows maxidoux qui
caruana ça me choque heure aimer caruana
doit être en fond de tableau
aïe je vous conte
m en plus c'est intéressant c'est un
jeune je crois que dans
doudine plutôt dangereux
ça va être chaud
sept ans est dangereux
parce sur hello
oh
beau maxime
qui est double et blanc fram ont gagné
la pas le choix l'aïe a pas le choix
c'est là
sans rien de temps à partie dans trois
minutes
globe c'est presque way club globe c'est
presque le pain quoi pas tout à fait à
une lettre près
il s'appelle ben en quoi
votre niveau de malaise mais très très
bien je vendais justin barcia
aujourd'hui mais quand même énormément
enfin s'il te plaît coiffe un tutu mais
une mauvaise ambiance anxiogène j'ai
quasiment être obligé de te battre parce
que tant que ce gène
tu nous ce gène is to le live en fait
c'est terrible
attendre ce gène pas tranquille
tranquille tranquille un faux pas on va
pas sanctionné nisé et les games sont
déjà assez anxiogène comme ça
max ap 22 09 23 [ __ ] on est loin aller
faut gagner la plus le choix plus le
temps niaiser comme disent nos amis
québécois
allez bunga-bunga
serait pas un mamediarov ambulants la
cam
peut-être une façon maxime est loin
donc
la gagner pas le choix
voyez aller sur salat
ha ha et maxime la sallaz contre le jeu
n'y a pas le choix tu penses que s'ils
gagnent pas cette partie s'en sera fini
des espoirs du joueur français pour moi
c'est vraiment tracé on est haut dans le
tournoi mais c'est le révélateur si
maxime n'est pas capable de battre glèbe
doudine il va il fera pas un grand
tournoi c'est pas possible il ressort
l'espagnol
vsync au four b3
il faut absolument mettre le punto
poussé shinko la variante
non c'est pas une harangue un sachet
plus comment s'appelle je crois qu'il
avait joué du à cuatro ici maxime nom de
mémoire a laissé trois des six des 4 il
prend le centre on a déjà vu des
positions comme ça là je connais pas les
valent mais visuellement
visuellement ça a l'air cool de fou qui
vient ou 3 il n'ya pas de clé provokat
on avoue des 5 1 la petite double
attaque classique
qui avait l'épée des deux probablement
pour défendre le centre et se placer la
tour qui vit en b vite peut-être h3
maintenant pour interdire fou g4
intéressant d'interdire le fou g4 quand
on a joué des quatre ça permet que
lecavalier maintienne son contrôle du
centre ça va probablement être joué par
maxime
allais les joues bien ces espagnols il
faut prendre confiance il est fou g4 il
doit avoir quelque chose là dessus et se
dire que c'est pas un bon coup ici
peut-être simplement un décalage h6
l'adversaire qui va empêcher les fous g5
ou les cavaliers g5 h3 maintenant joué
par maxime et il va avoir des cases un
maxime peut-être cette case f5 pour
attaquer le rock il ya plus le fou en
est fluide pour le défendre a laissé une
position maxime est celle-là il sait les
jouer il est bon dans ses positions
maxime généralement
à cuatro il vient mettre la pression sur
les dames il va sûrement mais peut-être
même pas j'allais dire un b 4 mais pas
forcément ça tu y avoir un cavalier a
thing qu il va toucher le fou
éventuellement on va voir il peut aussi
mettre le fou en b 7 il a décidé
d'échanger une fois en d4 il veut mettre
la pression gleb mais le cas à lyon b 4
mai la fête des cavaliers detroit et
menaces faute à des cavaliers pros eux
quatre ils vont acheter les fouilles
bessette
c'était une variante sur tf1 que
certains appellent d'ailleurs l'avoir
ion de quatre chefs de la sicilienne
faut-il le rappeler sur québec a
peut-être un signe que non il fait
asymco il déplace il force fois cet os
il avoue prend fct dame b 3 où il a raté
il y avait peut-être pas vous pourrez
essayer trois premières cette dame b3 et
peut-être caïds et 5
maxime qui fait des cinq ils échangent
les fous
je ne sais pas je le trouve pas je le
trouve pas tranchant maxime dans ces
parties je le trouve pas tranchant j'ai
l'impression que c'est en une nouvelle
fois sur l'adversaire qui prend le
dessus peut-être un dame b1 pour cavaler
prend fou prend à cette dame à dos dames
à 5
ouais je le sens pas je le sens pas
tranchants comme d'habitude les coûts
sont pas flotte pas autant
voilà c'est deux parties elle peut faire
très mal au moral si réussis pas la
gagner son espagnol passe pas vraiment
tour des 3 allez faut mettre la pression
sur des six il faut faire de la magie
maintenant
il faut faire de la magie faut qu'ils
nous fassent ce qui fait qu'il était
numéro deux mondial maxime
cette dame sept cavaliers f1 qui a valu
aux trois cavaliers f5 aller [ __ ] wife
cette dame b3 bordel et le une fois
non mais [ __ ] il peut pas rater une
pièce on
n'essaie pas possible c'est pas possible
c'est pas maxime ça c'est pas maxime
maksim koupreïev cette île à tempo dans
son renne je crois prend dame b3 merci
au revoir
c'est pas le vrai maxime qu'on a
aujourd'hui
c'est un imposteur s'est passé parti il
enfin allez allez maxime et les dames b3
enfin il aura fallu trois tentatives
pour le trouver mais maintenant il ya
cavaliers des 5 c'est plus aussi simple
avec le fou en baisse est assez
incroyable il a raté trois fois la
tactique
trois fois on se croirait dans une soupe
battle les amis vous me demandiez c'est
encore death of battles quand on a en
face de nous c'est incroyable ça
n'allait ça y est il enfin trouver quoi
il doit pas être content maximin ça fuse
pas dans l'esprit or il n'est pas dans
son tournoi il n'est pas dans son
tournoi encore le français
mais allez enfin enfin la dame b3 qui
part et et globe qui a pris un coup sur
la carafe allez faut le finir pas le
choix faut la gagner ça la maxime
faut aller la chercher
pour la finir faut le finir glèbe
faut finir le petit il n'y a pas le
choix
d'amd trois échecs qui fait ma la glèbe
à la double attaque il n'avait rien vu
heureusement heureusement qu'il a eu un
parce qu'il aurait pas eu la troisième
fois là je crois que on lâche quitté le
tournoi il faut aller là finir il faut
il faut gagner il faut marquer un but du
genou du dos à la dugarry comme vous
voulez du bout du crampon du bout des
doigts mais il faut marquer allait
tourner trois maintenant et puis on
prend on voit un commencé son tour ces
trois étaient tellement une gaffe il a
fait tour ces trois qui est des 5es tour
des 3 on pourrait avoir la même position
avec 2 ans de plus côté maxime est allé
c'est pas grave chute 20 secondes pour
glèbe il faut le finir au hachoir
pas le choix maxime pas le choix il faut
prendre en d5 maintenant et ramener le
cavalier verser 6 ouvert aux 6 ses pions
de plus pour maxime interview de gâcher
munitions c'est interdit c'est trop
difficile à avoir une munition il faut
la mettre au fond celle là qui a relié
des 4es ski adam prend des cinq je crois
y aura cavalli prend cavaliers
non je crois que ça passe pour un
cavalier des quatre dames prend des 5 et
prend des cinq dames prend b3 qui est
prend des six qui les prend b3 cavaliers
des cuatro qui passa les maximes il faut
la voir il faut avoir tous les coups
maintenant se mettre en confiance pour
la suite allez le cavalier des cuatro
rouille sa part allait enfin les coûts
vers l'avant et caraïbes et sahin bim un
coup à gauche un coup à droite
allez allez maxime
bouffe lui ce plan b 5 es tu bouffes des
6 et voilà ça rentre et cavaliers
prendrait six échecs et cavaliers prend
b3 on lui marche dessus au gamin
cavaliers prend b3 et le quart eli qui
arrive en c5 ça va gagner les amis mais
que c'est laborieux et que c'est
laborieux assez dur hein c'est difficile
et là cavalier prend 17 qui va tomber sa
tombe dans quel sens comprend 17 qui est
pro b cette tour prend des trois encore
mais sur walfoot ya qui avait lui aussi
cessé abandon maxime qui met le pool tôt
mais que c'était dur que c'était dur
c'était vraiment vraiment difficile je
vais me montrer maxime qui va rater une
première fois fait preuve cette voie
premier set et dames b3 ils valent raté
une première fois puis un petit peu plus
tard il va leur raté une deuxième fois
un peu plus tard dans la partie il va de
nouveau le rater ici pour finalement
après tour ces trois fous bessette enfin
alléluia trouvé l'oeuf ou presque
c'était gagné la partie on va aller voir
ce qui se passe du côté d'ali reza qui
est peut-être encore en enjeu alireza au
noir contre aleksandar india l'iresa
dans le dur alireza peut-être en train
de se faire des crocs poney il a les
noirs là contre
contre une douche vous n'avez pas les
beaux noms mais c'est ali reza au noir
et il est complètement complètement fou
tu auras il va être décramponner de
joueurs français
ça va être il a perdu la l'iresa et ici
il reste il reste bloqué bloqué au
compteur bloqué à trois points sur trois
points sur sur six dans maxim à combien
maxime il avait quoi on est à 3 sur 5
ses affaires 3 sur 6 c'est terrible
terrible ali reza qui n'est pas dans le
rythme en dans ce tournoi
ali reza qui n'est pas dans le rythme
allait maxime qui a gagné maintenant on
va aller voir un peu ce qui se passe du
côté de magnus carlsen
uncam sur le champion du monde
joueront en régie on va pas voir les
coups il a les blancs contre fait d'os
feydeau ce qui est un joueur très
dangereux
il est dangereux fait d'os il est
il faut voir s'il réussit à faire
quelque chose
ce qu'il réussit à prendre dix points
maxime à magnus pardon il ya quoi y'a
une caldav ans mais lecavalier 6 est
fort j'ai du mal à évaluer c'est quoi
les pions un deux trois quatre cinq
contre cinq coups 6 contre 5 septembre
contre la cale le cavalier aussi ce qui
fait la rustine est
pro les douches pour une touche magnus
qui est peut-être en train de vaciller
parce qu'il ya pas tour prend b2 puis on
prend b2 tourbe est un gars fous ces
deux échecs hoya fous ces deux échecs et
mat magnus qui a perdu le champion du
monde qui va si je crois qu'il a perdu
et je suis pas sûr à 100% mais je crois
que c'est perdido le champion du monde
qui va si on voit pas
on voit pas mais il a vacillé ou pas
ça bug
ça me guay
voici ou pas il a gagné je sais pas
j'avais pas les coûts non plus de façon
assez gagné
signé incroyable magnus carlsen
qui s'incline
à incroyable
incroyable magnus à 4 sur 6 égalité avec
avec maxime et il va rester tableau 1
c'est là que je vous dis c'est un énorme
avantage pour magnus des sur caméra fixe
grâce à ses contrats télévisuels là
c'est vraiment là que ça fait la leaf
parce que sinon à 4 sur 6 tu te
retrouves table 10 tables neuf tableaux
10 et psychologiquement c'est difficile
alors que là ça va être un genre de
complexe de supériorité par rapport à
ses adversaires mais mais c'est celle
avantages du champion mais l'équité
sportive n'est n'est pas tout à fait
suivi on va dire
mais bon c'est comme ça c'est le
privilège du champion
saluera pas servi hier pour être
champion du monde de rapides mais la 4
sur 6 ça doit faire mal à la tête et
fedoseyev qui montre qu'il est fort sur
internet et pas qu'eux qu'ils prouvent
pourquoi il fait des bonds title tuesday
pour y avoir elle car le sénat les lots
sont trop proches qu'est-ce qui a eu
lieu et une fois dans les autres parties
signent d'art of great chioukh ça fait
nul est dangereux à l'ouzbek
mais du coup l'an prochain on va pisser
le caméra prestige en sera quand même
magnus qui sera pas champions du monde
mais qui sera quand même caméra fixe
comme tous les ans quoi qu'il en soit
parce qu'il ya l'année dernière il
n'était pas champion du monde il avait
quand même la caméra fixe quand même le
privilège du champion même quand il ne
l'est pas terrible
est ce que en dessous neeman dangereux
aussi contrôler par hinse a cédé très
gros joueur
je sais pas trop ce qui se passe à
oriane qui a battu matt la coff
chef
qui a perdu contenir le signal sarine je
crois qu'il ya un peu loin dans le
tournoi mais les 3200 sur chaise comme
un
champion du monde ça m'étonnerait
sur monument dans l'ombre en même temps
ils vendent
alors à toucher les pièces et pas dire
ja double il ya quand même beaucoup de
privilèges ah tiens ma fabiano caruana
contre le ca michaud coeur à mère de
famille qui a perdu c'est un pote
nous avons employé espérer un bon
résultat de samy
dommages et a perdu où j'aime bien ça
mis en joue ensemble en en jeunes
jouaient dans la même catégorie il car
où que 4 sur 6 bah il est dur le
tournant un
team qui est revenu
ensuite dans un élégant par michael mann
estime potable en robot s'il y avait que
ça
ouais mais rogers quand il éliminé il
joue plus le tournant en fait le truc
c'est que c'est pas un forme un format
coupe nature x hasard là c'est pas un
format coupe ces informations aucun
rapport avec le tennis en fête et le
truc du central au déni justement le
central c'est fait pour être vu mais là
ya pas de public ya pas de spectateurs
c'est juste un avantage comme ça a pas
vraiment de raison en soi
combien monde aujourd'hui 12
que magnus qui avantage mais on peut
importe un salut portera peut-être pas
bonheur
ratu peut les déplacer tu peux filmer
d'autres tables en vrai
croyais qu'il y avait moi je crois qu'il
y avait quoi moi je voi x et est vite
parti aujourd'hui et sète demain
parce que je passais les résultats alors
non parce qu'ils y sont pas ici
mais peut-être que je peux les trouver
quelque part
je veux que les montrer comme ça si tu
veux
pose pas du tout aujourd'hui l'on dépose
tout le temps en fait
ce moment et on voit que maxime est pas
si mal il doit être à quatre points je
le vois
leur classement est claquée au sol parce
que maxime il un 4 sur 6 et il est pas
noté donc
le design est beau
mais y'a pas tous les joueurs donc c'est
un problème en fait il est très très
beau le design au ca pour être beau il
est beau
il est beau le classement mais en fait
on n'a pas le bon classement
on est d'accord que maxime à 4
maintenant j'ai les jeux doute il a
trois et demi
il a quatre
il a quatre si c'est vrai c'est sûr
le truc est pas forcément totalement à
jour mais on voit quand même le haut du
tableau fait d'os mam et
kraft kraft steve sawtche co cinda rohff
grisha martirossian vannes eux
6 ça pue un peu quand même ça dépend la
gousse tin oo tante avait fait un
commentaire très intelligent il ya pas
si longtemps autant là
pas terrible commentaires moi ce qui me
fait peur c'est les coûts de maxime il
rate fou prend effet à trois fois
d'affilée
moi c'est les coups qui me font peur
moi ce sont les coups qui me font peur
c'est pas le classement c'est les coûts
juste inquiet des coups c'est tout
et coup c'est important et quand il n'ya
pas les coups c'est inquiétant mais bon
il est pas il n'est pas largué maxime
icart ou là on va voir si c'est le
meilleur joueur du monde en blitz ainsi
c'est le meilleur boxeur du monde il va
finir premiers a ici c'est pas le cas il
sera pas premier en fait c'est aussi
simple que ça
ça c'est très simple atteint
les queens je pense qu'ils voient pas
les coûts aux sardes
je crois qu'ils voient pas les coûts
au premier set il l'avait pas c'est sûr
effet de la noxe l'entente appareils
ouais mais après en quinze
participations si tu es le meilleur tu
vas quand même gagné une fois
sarr actualisé
je sais pas j'ai il actualise
réactualisé maxime en fait il peut pas
être dans le top ce qui l'a 4 donc il
est derrière tous ces gars là
beaucoup de gens qui pensent qu'ils
croient le meilleur joueur du monde en
blitz mais ouais ça se vérifie pas du
tout en fait
top 3 clairement en top 3 top 5 depuis
longtemps mais tapez 1 je pense magnus
au dessus en fait à leur manière gagné
plusieurs fois championne du monde deux
listes
championnat car on n'en a jamais
ça
sarina et fab ah ben ça rime quand même
3200 sur jazz comme donc attention grand
favori du tournoi
bah oui il doit être vraiment très fort
travail le sens sur pièces comme
attention hein wim détrompe-toi kevin
c'est vraiment un des favoris de ce
tournoi de blitz ponts c'est par un
si on continue à gagner moi ce qu'un
julien ce qui m'inquiète c'est son
niveau de jeu que je trouve très en deçà
de ce qu'il est capable de faire après
le blitz et aussi des vagues
peut-être qu'il va se réveiller mais
pour le moment je le trouve où loin de
son meilleur niveau
parce que sa peinture
lui s'en fout en fait j'ai aucune chance
de gagner donc non ça n'a aucun intérêt
en fait
ça à quoi de jouer en fait c'est
regarder non qui sont devant absolument
aucune chance un parent à 0,001 c'est 0
0000 en fait
maintenant s'il ya des joueurs des
joueuses françaises qui jouent aux
sardes mais bon c'est
c'est loin du top
bientôt reprendre dans six minutes
meiway maximin il ya deux ans c'était
vrai
mais on sent qu'à une petite régression
rapide et ambitieux on va voir où une
progression des autres
pour maxime maxime fou qui commence à
jouer les coups c'est to be gagne là il
joue qui d'ailleurs on va voir on va
aller regarder
il doit jouer au noir j'imagine
prête que karlsson a fait une très belle
vidéo pour noël avec fable sur un
sacrifice de dames de prêtres que ce
qu'ils ont vu
au cas où il joue contre varie dof c'est
pas le pas le bonus bec
à maxime qui jouent contre le site off
side of wayne qui est passé par
marseille pour ceux qui suivent un petit
peu
si tu vas passer par marseille
retourné après en russie
6000 fasse mal
monica ce que je pensais à ça c'est pas
la femme monica secours
fava nous dit hrw avait trop courants
faibles connaît les dossiers
c'est la femme toujours su
j'ai toujours su
toujours suis très important
nous il est où
je sais pas il va rien faire en fait
c'est parce qu'il est champion de
rapides qu'il est pas nul en fait hein
faut
raison garder un tube ou dix fois il
gagne deux mille fois championnat du
monde de rapide il gagne une fois
maintenant aujourd'hui 12
non mais reste un plot quand même quoi
mais ces douze aujourd'hui on se demande
c'est 23 rond dans tous
ces 12 et 9
afari hockey
les gens pour mb ap alors que c'est
peut-être que oui peut-être que non en
fait on ne sait pas on peut pas dire en
fait
un an juste on faisait pas très logique
de faire 12 et 9
logique s'arrêter de faire 11 et 10
mais bon
alors juste cammas est logique de faire
11 et 18 21 ans de plus que douze et
neuf mais pourquoi pas un
12 c'est le temps de 6 des partages a
cédé partage à deux de façon
assez un départage fait un départage fin
haletante quoi
c'est peut-être pour la cérémonie de
clôture est
vraiment illogique en soi même on peut
importe
des barrages ce service avec la finale
de la coupe du monde on devrait l'avancé
à 18h30 sur le lien m à 21h si jamais il
ya des terreaux but et pour la cérémonie
de clôture de la coupe du monde de foot
je pense fort est avancée pour la ligue
des champions pareil sait jamais ça les
tirs au but fort avec ça ça commence
bien avant pour on ne sait jamais si les
tirs au but ah ça oui de couture en
tellement de temps pour être bien sûr
que le 3 fait avant 21h soit rubicon
puissent éteindre les lumières quoi
dire ça n'étonne pas un pour le
championnat du monde car la scène n'est
point ils ont besoin de trois jours
après pour organiser la serbie de
clôture parce que bon fallait bien
soufflé ou deux jours chez plus mais ça
n'a pas eu lieu dans la foulée il
fallait vraiment souffler le temps de
être vraiment bien sûr de remettre le
trophée
ça oui clôture travaillé très très
difficile à organiser
je vous tue souffle déjà souffert et
c'est vrai qu'ici y mettre les dates de
début de tournoi sont jamais les vrais
date de début mai c'est le date de la
cérémonie d'ouverture la veille pour
vraiment être sûr
allez c'est parti les amis sytchev qui
envoie le quattro l'attaquant de
l'olympique de marseille
qui décide d'envoyer cat et maxime qui
joue la sicile et n allez fini fini de
blaguer on va envoyer des petites taches
dorff le fou gesing koki par
maxime jouer aux six f4 c'est une langue
qu'on lui a beaucoup joué dernièrement
dame b 6
allez on tape on tape sur le pion b2
c'est la variante du pion dit empoisonné
mais maxime le manche quand même il à
l'antidote oh que oui oh que oui il a il
a les trois doses d'antidote 1 contre ce
pion b2 alors là et au charisme il ya un
problème avec l'échiquier qui arrivait à
l'instant et sa part alors il ya plus on
prend 1,5 si on prend et qui a validé
cette
maxime kia qui a une qui a une bonne une
bonne position ici
à l'écart et lieu 4 il va jouer cavalier
prend aux saints qui sinon dame prend à
deux tours d un la dame qui va revenir
en dessine co
les dates des cinq pour aller attaquer
le puriste je crois que c'est encore
théorique en vraie dame e3 jouer dame
prend 1,5 c'est vraiment une grande
variante du pion empoisonné on va voir
on va voir ce que ça donne
on va voir ce que ça donne et skull
dames 5 va passer
de fous ces cinq ça ressemble à sa
partie contre caruana en vrai de vrai
adversaire a dû réviser juste avant
c'est terrible d'en prendre cinq fois
deux fous ces 5
va mettre le fou en g3 il retape la dam
dam des cinq
c4 fou prend des quatre là il se hisse
on voit la théorie dans la gueule en
fait tu en prends des quatre dames à
sainte-maxime connaît encore c'est la
bonne nouvelle
il va jouer le petit rock maintenant
il va jouer petit rock et qui va laisser
six cavaliers 5 qui va partir
si le peu fou des six f5 maxime qui
continuent à cliquer tempo il est très à
l'aise dans cette position
trois pions de plus mais mais il a rendu
une cale et maintenant il va falloir un
petit peu résisté il va mettre le
cavalier en 17 d'ailleurs petit rat qui
va partir dame ces cinq peut-être
échanger les dames et joue avec les
trios chpwn tosh
les triages countach qui peuvent faire
mal en finale maxime est généralement un
orfèvre dans ce genre de position
il les joue très très bien ces finales
avec avec qualité de moins ou tu pousse
ses pions
il fait très mal
sur dix en france inquiet français 5
et après les pions qui vont partir il va
tenter de faire fou 17 pouces et 6
maxime et envoyait les pions ouais je
trouve qu'il est bien là j'aime beaucoup
la position des noirs a laissé une
partie vraiment
déterminante roy f2 il bien se préparer
pour la finale donc du coup ils veulent
et c'est maxime initial échange une
maxime envoie le pion à saillé il part à
5 à 4 à 3 il peut aller se placer
jusqu'à 3 attention quand même ne pas se
faire prendre par les tours
ça va être une position complexe il peut
aussi avoir des idées peut-être demandé
2,5 kg a valu aussi s'il y arrive ça va
pas être ça va pas être simple pour pour
six chefs de défendre si maxime joue à
son niveau maximal à gagner celle-là il
ya trop d'activités trop de tactique
tour b 1 il tape un peu sur bessette
est ce qu'il peut faire f4 provoquer
mais les pions serait trop détaché est
sûr c'est qu'il ya un problème avec le
pion f5 allez il faut trouver un truc
ici
b6 a pas l'air d'être top non plus parce
que sur dame français 5 on pourra plus
prendre du cavalier faudra tenir le pion
et à 4 à 4 c'est un peu de gestes
à 4 un peu de gestes pour le moment le
problème c'est que l'option est vraiment
éloigné émanant du soutien voilà encore
un petit peu comme au rugby un genre de
bastareaud qui part
qui évite de trois plaquages mais ce qui
se retrouve un peu esseulé dans la
défense adverse
dams et 7 il garde les dames du coup
pour
garder plus de possibilités défendent le
pion ses cinquièmes ali hafsi s'il va
amener l'autre cavaliers en dix-sept
peut-être celui-là en d5 il ya karine
icher 4 aussi qui peut exister si le fou
est déviée n'y a pas de fous 17 à cause
de tout reprendre et 7 pour le moment
mais attention à la dame attaché aux
pions il ya des échecs il ya beaucoup de
casse des chèques ici fouet f3 jouer
alors il me menace pas vraiment de
prendre en bessin j'imagine puisque
quatre autres cavaliers g4 dans leur âge
et maintenant peut-être cavaliers g6
pour cavaliers aux sept cavaliers des
cinq pour maxime ça peut être une option
c'est pas forcément la seule mais c'est
clairement une option de jeu torah 5 j'y
crois pas trop à 3 peut aussi est une
idée pour désorganiser les pièces verdel
dame est peut-être essayer de contre
attaquer au centre par la suite
maxime qui doit faire le bon choix ici
même fois elle fut en fout des sept
tours prendrait cette dame à 5 j crois
pas trop
allez peut-être à 3 envoyé le pion comme
un bellier tourbe et 8 il décide à il
veut jouer p6 maxime il veut faire péter
s'est passé 6 le coin il veut faire
péter le centre
il veut faire péter le centre
et le cavalier en d6
et surbaissé fo à 6 ou quelque chose
comme ça avait six fois ci c b 5e ci
peut être une idée dans quelques monde
mais y aura un cavalier fragile en des
six
tours
bbb deux skis la b6 maintenant ou pas
non il veut tout prendre en b 6 3 7 5 ou
que j'aime bien ça permet de ne jamais
se prendre un dame aussi sur échec et de
s'éloigner du conflit et maintenant
cavalier g6 c'est sûr qu'il va les
français 8 dames france et 8 mois n'y a
plus jamais de problème ici en fait donc
ça c'est bien joué le coup à je crois de
six chefs étaient aussi assez bons il
évite les cavaliers g4 allez maintenant
il va falloir envoyer peut-être du
cavalier h4 il fait tout reprend du coup
il faut prendre 17 il veut quoi il veut
autour des 8 et jouer la taca les maxima
peut-être la pause la clique deux pions
pour la calmer il a vraiment de
l'activité ici tour des huit qui part et
aux 5,4 qui peut y aller fouet trois
cavaliers 5 je veux juste revenir ce que
leur dit donné gagnant après damage deux
arrêts damage de cavaler h4 raté par
maxime et qui a valu au s'inquiète un
joli coup plus de 30 secondes pour site
chauffe sytchev en grande difficulté ici
cavalier e 5 ha sur tourbe et cette île
adam prend d'armes français 5 et d 3 qui
est français 5 où il a une très très
belle position ici le joueur français et
la dame français 5 j'imagine prise
qu'avec des trois quilles et c5 et il ya
les triages puntos le spawn touche
l'ordinateur d'un égal mais visuellement
c'est complètement gagnant pour les
noirs ouais je pense qu'il va le faire
le taf ici il doit être très confiant
maxime dans cette position de cavaliers
qui va venir en c5 croquer la dame la
tour qui vient à 7 et les punto ch le
spawn tosh loge pétoche aller sa part à
les époux josh on avance on avance tour
17 il veut échanger les tours c'est très
bien joué aussi tout reprend 17 non il
fait tour torah 5 il a bien raison et la
tour qui va venir à tours c'est cette
île veut tour ces deux s'est bien
défendue de la part de sites chauffe
s'est très bien défendu tour torah 5 un
excellent coup maxime qui part sur kébé
trois tours prend à quatre quais et des
quatre et il va falloir faire pousser
les punto ch alé lô staunton ils y vont
ils sont à deux doigts d'y aller de ktef
4 3 elle sait bien jouer tour d2 il veut
bloquer l'avancée du pion
on s'en prenant cavaliers tour c'est
cette île se décale la tour qui va venir
en c1 sur échec et on va peut-être
essayer g5 3g 6h 5 g 4 quattro chpwn
tosh ils peuvent y aller pour ces deux
temps des deux tours c'est cette
maxime qui est un petit peu réputés les
coups il a gagné sa dû tomber côté
côté russe il ya écrit 1 0 et gagne à
dos merci au revoir mesdames et
messieurs n'y a pas eu de nul ici un
j'annonce ça a dû tomber côté côté
sytchev ça rappelle ses belles années à
l'om terrible maxime qui l'emportent on
va aller voir les autres les autres
résultats car le scène qui a battu prête
que et nakamura n'a qu'un mur a
peut-être en difficulté on va le voir
peut-être que nakamura est en grande
difficulté
ici avec les pièces blanches contre vos
rides of chamsidine allez mon petit vos
rides ou c'est l'heure de faire chuter
le streamer
il faut qu'il essaye de lui mettre la
pression quand même faire tomber car où
ça pourrait faire du bien la position a
l'air d'être nul et yahoo qui pourraient
être bloqués et 1 4 point sur sept ça
mettrait très bien autoproclamé meilleur
joueur de blitz du monde mais qui peut
qui souffre la face à un très jeune
joueur ouzbek
il va peut-être essayé d'envoyer roi g5y
f5 à l'ouzbek pour reprendre du point e
et envoyer les deux puntos
sa part sa part la tour qui va venir e4
la tour en 1 en d1 derrière les pions et
ça va partir lauch puntos hikawa à deux
doigts de perdre encore et se retrouver
dans les fins fonds du classement
allez il faut faire le taf côté côté vos
rides off c'est pas facile de battre le
streamer américain et il peut le faire
il peut le faire tu es grand tu peux y
arriver mais je pense qu'il n'y arrive
pas du tout mais il peut y arriver
peut-être
il faut faire voir chez 3 f 4g car il
faut dire que l'ouzbékistan depuis que
murtaza a déménagé à tachkent est un
créateur d'espoir on peut les les cités
sinndar of douce à toronto rid of et
mirta ce n'est probablement pas étranger
à tout ça attention de pas se prendre
tomber quatre tons des quatre lacs ou
bada
attention on les a mis ça peut être
extrêmement dangereux et ça va faire nul
vori d'offres qui échoue il a
probablement été gagnant un moment mais
il va prendre le demi point et ralentir
tout de même le streamer dans sa quête
d'un premier et unique titre de champion
du monde ça va être difficile pour
hikaru de briller dans ce tournoi
il va être bloquée la 4.1 et demi sur
quatre points et demi sur cette longue
lui est
englué dans le ventre mou du classement
alors qu ali reza a lui aussi était
était dans le dur
qui ont déjà qui a battu pau ce n'est en
bosnie en sueur
gagner
cherches tu cherches micha
aux longs cheveux sont et dans la gueule
de misha hausse est magnifique et na qui
cherche le chausson et micha 49e ce qui
a le chausson dans la gueule qui est en
train de marcher
robichaud aide magnifique
omis chat qui se présente un procédé
dans présentation ils pas qu'ils
auraient aimé être là
haut que oui
chaque parent le chausson
on va revoir le classement qui va pas
être à jour
avec martin crafts je recrée n'y un
inconnu au bataillon leader du tournoi
seuls en tête avec 6 points et demi sur
7 devant shahriyar mamediarov vladimir
fedoseyev et jaillot wir sind art of on
n'a pas le bonus beck qui est quatrième
au classement ait martirossian great
choukhevitch duda qui suivent les vents
qui est debout dans ce tournoi il était
en difficulté dans le rapide mais il est
là dan il dit bof
bartosz sochko à cinq points un petit
peu d'air dans le dans le groupe qu'on
va appeler le groupe mvl karl scène il
va falloir voir lequel lequel des deux
leaders va se mettre devant le groupe
pour rouler maxi va pas avoir envie de
prendre le vent il ya peut-être se
mettre dans l'est dans les roues de
magnus en lui disant c'est toi le patron
c'est toi le maillot jaune c'est à toi
de faire le boulot je crois pas que la
norvège est vraiment des équipiers à
faire rouler dans ce groupe à 5 sur 7 et
ouais ça va être au leader la d'assumer
pour pour aller chercher l'échappée
crafts
partie dès les premiers kilomètres
même les premiers hectomètres et qui a
une
grande avance sur sur ses adversaires
mais mais il ya quand même plusieurs
groupes 1 derrière pour aller le
chercher
on va voir ce que ça donne
faut prendre du sommet je pense maxime
doit se mettre dans la roue du saumon et
le laisser rouler
bon il faut pas faire
comme gaudiot jeux olympiques
par contre s était resté dans les roues
et je vais aller prendre une attaque et
quand le coup avec carapace est parti en
art n'a pas pu ramener tout le monde
n'a pas fait recette même erreur côté
mvl il savoir prendre les relais quand
il le faut
complexe
alors voir maxime qui apparaît donc
classement à cinq points sur sept il est
là il a il a gagné au noir avec sa nage
dorff
maxime dans le groupe car la scène les
pommiers à chiba est aux deux hommes de
faire le boulot
firoud dans le gruppetto pour le moment
maso qui n'est pas dans le tournoi qui
peut pas faire son rôle d'équipier pour
remonter ali rezaï va devoir faire le
travail tout seul
joueuse russe a en tête du tournoi
shuvalova mariage qui n'a goût nina
bibi sarr a aussi fait partie des
favorites
jusqu'à zac aussi très forte elle aussi
sous l'influencé de mur tu as bien
entendu
on va attendre quinze minutes la
prochaine ronde
alireza dans le peloton et
ami
avec cissé offredo qui part en échappée
sur le plat en première semaine c'est
tellement ça
point il à 4 sur 7 un demi point
derrière derrière hikaru donc il est
loin
mais il peut revenir
on voulait qu'on suive un peu plus le
ton en délire et zara là pour le moment
mais qu'on arrête un peu de suivre
maxime et qu'on aille un peu voir ce qui
se passe quand ali reza
non je déconne
frans steyn blague
assez pour troll
je le troll et je troll et c'est bon
il faut bien un peu trop lun
à jeu vient de mettre la pub tiens
parlant de ça
je vais oublier de mettre la pub à la
pub adha
allez faut que max gagner encore s'ils
gagnent encore cela ils se replacent
vraiment c'est ça la ccssl qui peut
rattraper les le mauvais début
du coup est ce que ça nous serve
vraiment les caméras dans ce tournoi où
parents vrai
pas vraiment
en vrai
balle dans le pied pour air quasiment ça
peut nous servir qu'à la fin quoi
ouais ici peu de caméras c'est sarah r
mais encore
il ya que deux tables qui sont filmés
donc ça va être dur hein
on est loin encore
table au moins qui est éditable ce que
je disais en fait dit ah ben ça me
paraissait bien j'avais dix tables on
verrait de nouveau maxime en fait et
c'était normal de ne pas le voir quand
il était de loin au classement mais
équitable ça me paraît quand même normal
quand tu retransmet une compétition
à lagny vite devant après le réveil
d'autres adversaires mais il s'est
peut-être chauffer la maxime il a mieux
joué celle-là la précédente
voir ce que font les autres en attend
bah c'est bon c'est fait c'est fini les
autres partis
l'aïe a plus de parti tu vas bien
l'image a plus personne on attend les
prochaines
je crois pas un pré leur classement il
n'est pas très bien foutu
leur classement est tellement mal foutu
leur truc
qui décide de qui qui c'est une formule
mathématique en fait
roula sur internet mais il est déjà
passé mais en fait il viendra jamais
comme maxime ou
baky et déjà il parle pas pour un papa
je paye parle un peu français mais par
déjà pas couramment français donc c'est
un peu disqualifiant quoi
parler français est quand même important
c'est une chaîne avant d'être française
qui est francophone vladmir tu as tout
ça et par le français
même s'ils sont pas français
brad ci mais mirta ce nom
le français en deux ans ça dépend si tu
travailles si tu trouves pas en fait ça
dépend des situations
genre ma femme quand elle est devenue
française elle parlait déjà français
couramment
regarde d'aidé elle parle français
couramment aussi ça dépend
l'implication de ta
mais moi il finira par parler un jour ou
l'autre
ouais son frère il parle bien ouais
français son frère il parle bien
c'est raciste de ressort que des
francophones à lézan qu'est ce qu'il
faut pas lire dans ce chat c'est
terrible
vu qu'on parle français c'est à des gens
qui parlent une autre langue on aura du
mal alors parler quoi fin
c'est quand même complexe à quesques il
faut pas lire dans le chatt
s'être compliqué de parler avec des gens
qui parlent des langues qu'on comprend
pas quoi
fois le level du chat fait peur
c'est complexe
c'est complexe jonquière le chat web
c'est complexe fait comprendre qu'on
voit c'est la remarque intelligente est
à l'arrêt
on va essayer de récupérer les tables
non j'ai pas les noms
ça commence j'ai pas les appariements
j'entends que les arbitres sont en train
de s'inventer des life
les appariements semble être sorti ici
aronian grisha
karl st gall fendent
prêtre
punto is i
am fait halte cff il ya une anecdote
marrante la première et seule fois que
j'ai joué en équipe de france à aux
olympiades ces olympiades jeunes mais la
première partie que j'ai joué c'était
contre timofei fo noir vous allez
retrouver dans la base d'une carreaux
cannes j'étais pas mal et puis il fut
j'ai perdu
et en fait l'anecdote est pas fini c'est
que j'ai revu timofeï f 10 ans après ça
à moscou quand je vivais là bas
et donc je suis retrouvé à la même table
que lui dans un dîner de clôture d'un
tournoi et donc je dis bonjour je me dis
bon il se rappelle pas à moi et ils
connaissaient pas vraiment mon nom en
fait il me voit on dîne ensemble et
peut-être après 10 15 8 il me dit mais
attends j'ai pas joué une partie contre
toi olympiades jeunes artec une carreaux
cannes bat judici il me dit will je me
rappelais bon bah bravo quoi
enfin bravo à toi combien ils sont
rappelés quoi il se rappelait de la
deûle à carreaux cannes
marrant quoi
il se rappelait de la game il a toujours
su jouer mais c'était pas une mauvaise
partie ça m'étonne pas qu'ils s'en
rappelait fin j'aurais pu avoir oublié
mais comme c'était une bonne partie
tendue et tous ces partis dont tu te
rappelles généralement plus mais c'était
marrant
tu vas
on s'en fout on faisait partie que je
voyais à 20 ans a aucun intérêt
mais ses parents qui s'en rappeler
on est parti de merde
maintenant ils avaient bien cliquer
c'est un pion isolé j'avais pas réussi à
mettre les barbelés comme il fallait je
pensais être mis au monde au nez et j'ai
trop pleutres
j'espère qu'on va voir la partie qui va
venir
bah oui quand même
et je vais quand même contre des équipes
de plomb on a émis 4 0 à la belgique je
me rappelle de ça aussi
l'empulse qu'avant le match on se disait
que
ce serait la honte si un des joueurs
gagnaient pas contre les belges quoi
j'ai vraiment leur maître 4 0 je me
rappelle aussi bien parce que j'étais le
dernier à jouer et trois autres avaient
gagné moi j'ai galéré à gagner je sus et
contre le joueur belge la goutte sur le
front et [ __ ] faut pas que je le rate
si on fait que trois et demi sur 4 je
vais me faire trop chambrer
on avait fait 4 0 quand même
mais ça je rappelle qu'on voulait mettre
tarifs aux belges quelques petits trucs
dont je me rappelle
je rappelle aussi qu avant l'
appariement de la dernière ronde
on voit les israéliens qui qui exultent
de joie quand il voit les appariements
on nous on était un peu derrière on s'en
foutait un aussi bon soit on joue demain
on va voir
écran tour d'aller voir les appariements
on a vu qu il exultait de joie parce
qu'y jouer contre nous
j'ai pas trop compris la rave quoi il
pensait qu'on était tellement nuls
j'étais très heureux de nous jouer
extraordinaire
il était là genre ouais il se taper dans
la main bonne a pareillement qu'auront
view vent on verra bien compte qu'ils
vont s'en fout coiffe
1,6 foutez de notre gueule en fait
dai a gagné on a perdu deux et demi un
ennemi moi j'ai fait nul dans une partie
qui est dans la base aussi c'était une
française je sais pas très bien mais
j'avais bien serrée après j'avais mis
quelques petits barbelés
pareillement ouais mais en fait c'était
vrai il n'était pas très fort non plus
en fait nous on était faible et aussi
donc c'est bien tombé à l'est maxime qui
est au noir la petite anglaise envoyé
par par thibaut faye fc 4 5 3 il prépare
le des cuatro
il prépare le des cuatro le frérot russe
et il va falloir que maxime
mais tu prends les barbelés peut-être
pas au début barbelés et puis après on
va lui tirer dessus allez-vous bekkat
rock il va y avoir un dessin qui va
partir c'est un peu un genre de
sicilienne à l'envers en fait les blancs
sont les noirs les noirs sont les blancs
il prend du cavalier tour 8es des 5 1
qui devrait partir tôt ou tard pour
prendre le centre les blancs ont
davantage de la paire de fou mais les
noirs ont davantage du centre maxime qui
reprend du cavalier petit rock il va se
développer peut-être un ccico 1 pour
jouer un netto de ma roxy le détroit qui
paraît peut-être c5 et audemars auxi
pour tenir les cases puis cavaliers c6
vous aussi ce dame des sept tours 8 b6
f6 le grand classique les pièces vont
arriver sur les cases maxime qui joue
pas les taux qui met le quart alliance
et 6 directement il a une autre idée
derrière la tête fou aux six sur la
radio 4 il va peut-être devoir jouer un
b6 quand même j'ai pas trop aimé kessé 6
personnellement mais ça doit exister
dame c2a les dames 17 tours des 8 on
n'en parle plus
dams est joué maxime qui se développe
mais carey lieu quatre et c5 tu vas peut
faire mal quand même dans ses positions
il faut faire attention à lecavalier
serait bien placé il va taper sur le fou
aussi c'est sur le pion bessette et
peut-être sur qui avait lieu 4 il veut
tour des huit cavaliers c'est sinko est
fou c'est 8 pour venir tout blindés
ouais c'est ce qu'ils jouent autour des
8 mais bon il ya du p4 qui va partir
dubé 5 du a4 du four b2 et timofei elle
joue bien ce genre de position st c'est
un rouscoff ça joue sajou stratégique sa
clique bien
il ya un joueur qualitatif un joueur de
type stratège
peut-être un petit ainsi soit il empêche
b5 le fou qui arrive en b2c une c'est
une souffrance ici pour maxime c'est une
souffrante fouet f 5 pieds 5 pouces et 8
le fou qui va quasiment être dernière
partir sur sa case de départ c'est
maintenant chose faite ils ans et 8 le
fou qui vient en f3 et peut-être un f54
un jour mais il a l'air d'en il en est
loin peut-être h6 un petit coup parce
qu'on sait pas trop quoi faire mais
regardez les fous qui découpe en deux
katanas côté blanc et maxime qui a pas
de pas de jeu je pense qu'ils auraient
vraiment dû mettre ce pioncer sinko le
f5 et est trop prématuré trop optimistes
cavalier à cette maxime qui prend les
bordures
ses complexes cavaliers à sept îles
beaucoup évoqué db5 qui a aidé 6 essayer
de se libérer je sais même pas ce qu'il
veut en réalité il peu cavalier b5 ça
c'est sûr mais c'est quoi le prochain
coup il veut quoi etc et b5 c6 qui a
laissé cette cavale ie6 f 5 carats les
g5 est vraiment faire les bordures ça ce
serait un plan vraiment incroyable un
cavalier à cette baie cinq des six qui a
et b 5 c 6 et 7 6 puis j'ai 5 ce serait
un plan de marloux mais on sait que
maxime est très adroit avec les chevaux
et il va peut-être à ces plans qui joue
incroyable ce plan
maxime qui se présentent un cavalier à
cette baie 5 c 7 6 pour f simcoe cavalli
g5 il faut la voir dans de rennes j'ai
maintenant que le cavalier partir c'est
ça qu'on va aller vers des six on va
aller vers des six du coup maxime qui
prend la priorité de la case centrale
et c'est vraiment très bien joué de la
part du français
cavalli m6 il se replace un peu pour
dieu quattro pour du fou j'ai quattro
aulas on a un grand maxime là sur les
derniers coups il a serré 1 il a serré
la vis de 3 barbelés et là ils
recommencent à avoir une position
jouable on recommence à espérer une mc
match nul ne serait pas mauvais dans sa
quête du titre dans sa quête du graal
mais une défaite serait évidemment
embêtante allez y fait rage six tours d1
il va falloir clic maintenant est-ce
qu'il va cliquer ans et 7 et aussi ce
peut-être pour cliquant g5 je pense que
c'est le plan qu'il a en tête non il
clique à il veut cliquez dès 6 7 5 et et
h4 mais il va y avoir du g3 un moment
donné qui va éteindre les espoirs de
ceux de ses cavaliers mais il tient
aussi la case de karachi peut avoir
d'yeux quattro dans leur âge maxime qui
fait sa partie pour le moment
l'ouverture a été a été difficile mais
petit à petit se remet bien le fou qui
peut partir en f5 aussi un revenir
maintenant que lecavalier en d6 à
rustines et le pion bessette
il faut l 5 qui peut arriver timofei et
qui marque un premier temps d'arrêt dans
cette partie maxime qui va pouvoir
commencer à mettre la pression sur la
pendule et élargir le combat et le
conflit comme le disait mon entraîneur à
quatre cavaliers h7 tempo il veut
cavaliers j'ai cinq cavaliers f 5 carats
les h4 le marlou et de sorties touche
pas au grisbi timo faye f et oui il va
falloir faire attention parce que là
c'est les chevaux de maxime qui
s'approche du roi et ça peut aller très
vite au au quattro ça commence à choke
côté côté russe ça donne la casse des 4
et maintenant le cavalier va être éjecté
hollande y donne déjà b6 qui est proche
roi fou proches 3
ça commence à chauffer il va pas le
jouer maxime mais ça comme au foot
proches 3 pour aller jouer la case et la
case f4 hausse et maxime est ce que ça
allait mais maxime c'est peut-être
maintenant c'est maintenant qu'il faut
mettre l'accélérateur et faire ce que tu
sais si bien faire mettre la pression il
fait damev sissi est en train de le
préparer il prépare le fourrage 3 maxime
ils le préparent aux attentions timo
fait hier ça peut faire mal ça peut
faire très mal maxime en attaque
maintenant dans cette partie il est il a
replacé ces pièces regarder cet orfèvre
des échecs qui allait me remettre le
carillon g5 c'est un horloger maxime et
il n'y a pas d'erreur de temps c'est pal
sncf un sage oublie tout de suite le fou
qui vit à angers 4 pour colmater maxime
qui va devoir se séparer du fou mais
c'est pas encore fait un pour maxime
poundje et 4 c'était le seul coup pour
un team of eev qui trouve les barbelés
aussi de son côté cavalier au cices et
maintenant il va revenir avec la d'armes
aussi se faire f 6 la position est
peut-être pas si avantageuse pour maxime
est en tout cas maintenant c'est du jeu
à trois résultats et timofey ya pas plus
trop de temps mais médée beau barbelés
là il met tous les pions sur blanc il
réussit à bien blindé f6 maxime qui
blindent les pions noirs décati pouces
vous prend des quatre c'est peut-être de
nouveaux teams of eev qui a les devants
dans cette partie cavaliere cette maxime
qui va dépendre il faut pas faire comme
contre visite il y à quelques heures de
sa et est forcé le gars il faut accepter
la nulle au cas où le théâtre qui va
revenir en des huit maxime qui va
essayer de jouer avec la dame et le
cavalier contre contre le dame fou ça
peut être à l'avantagé du joueur
français mais attention il ya quatre ans
devant le roi blanc il y en a que 3
devant le roi noir la position est très
tendue il va falloir réussir à percer un
petit peu cette défense et à rentrer
dans la position inverse autour des 8 et
joue et on prend des buts qu'elle prend
des huit qui va arriver et les blancs
qui ont essayé de mettre la pression sur
les cases noires et sur le roi le fou
qui débarque en d4 maxime qui remet son
cavalier f7 il va essayer de revenir
peut-être vers des sites peut-être vers
ses cartes avec un point b 5 ça peut
partir côté maxime d'imhoff eev qui est
aussi là dans sa partie c'est très serré
c'est une partie très importante pour
l'avenir de maxime dans ce tournoi pour
sa carrière j'ai même envie de dire il
va falloir aller le chercher il peut
envoyer le cac valeo estime qu il peut
la voyant des six email à d'avant 17 il
est plus solide il s'en prend un petit
peu fou ya peut-être des dames d'am dam
des daims d'âme des uns ou dam des deux
qui partent cavaliers le carnet qui
revient aux six le fou qui est touché il
va venir aux trois avec ce fou maxime
qui a du mal quand même à percer b5 ils
se créèrent est peut-être un pion
arrière il peut pas vraiment le faire
peut-être la dame va venir en d6 pour
aller mettre pression sur le pion mais
timo fait hier pourrait jouer un coût de
1 à 5 et bloquer les pions les pions
maxime maxime qui fait un petit coup
droit achètent ils se décaleront de il
veut tenter peut-être un dam des trois
échanges et les dames puisque maintenant
le roi de maxime un petit peu en retard
et sur dame 7 ya eu cinq échecs
attentions seront achète et est mal
placé dame prend des trois fait peur
mais peut-être qu'il peut tenir là nul
en ramenant le roi rapidement maxime qui
est un choix importants à faire il a
plus de 30 secondes à la pendule il faut
jouer le coup ici d'1m75 ça fait quand
même très peur je pense que maxime va
échanger les dames ou alors tenter
d'amener cette pour aller s'en prendre
aux pions b4 ça a l'air d'être une
position complexe maxime qui tente le
tout pour le tout comme contre visite il
est venu avec des ambitions aujourd'hui
maxime il un piège que s'accroît g8
comme précis à cavalière quatre échecs
et sur wade de you're adam prend b4
s'est vu par timofeï f timofeievitch
aussi dans sa gamme dame prend des katja
plus de temps pour les deux c'est
extraordinaire ce qui est en train de se
passer peut-être en dame une dame 17
attention le roi peut être faible
cavaliers réussi c'est quand même bien
il ya le plan b 4 en l'air ya peut-être
du roi et vii d'imbéciles fait dame 17
il faut essayer de rentrer avec sa dame
timofeievitch peut peut-être repartir
avec au n'ont pas d'âme des huit qui
haïssez 7 qui est des cinq kilomètres
pression sur le plan b 4 et peut-être
aller du roi f7 les changes des dames et
proposer maintenant par le joueur russe
ça va être refusée par maxime avec dame
8 imaginer où il s'est joué maxime qui
veut pas de nulle part nul ici on va
aller chercher la wind il sait qu'il a
dans les jambes il a un petit mot fait
hier dans chaque doigt maxime mais la
position est dur le fou en c5 est très
bien placé dans le cadre proposé change
cavaliers c6 il attaque les deux pions
mano river avoir wave 3 et 7,5 et des
cinq rois ou 6 il va faire blocus la
position est difficile pour les deux
encore rien n'est fait mais ça doit
objectivement être nulle ivg 5 h 5 mais
ça m'étonnerait qu'il puisse percer ça
va terminer en nul les amis quelle
partie extraordinaire
quelle partie extraordinaire les amis
roi au 6ième g5 qui peut pas vraiment
cavaliers b8 attention fou j'ai sept
cavaliers à 6 est ce qu'il a encore du
ressort dans la position avec 1 c simcoe
qui parquet prend ses cinq le pion passé
b aux maximes qui donne tout un il la
joue jusqu'au bout maxime au bout du
bout ya peut-être max plongée 5
attention le cavalier qui arrive aux 5
maxime qui va aggraver le pion h4 maxime
qui va peut-être la gagner il est en
train de faire le taf il fait l'effort
maxime dans cette partie qu'elle
prendrait quatre à b5 h5 peut-être tout
le pion par maxime qui va faire qui a eu
lieu 3 et peut-être achetez un call et
il faut aller où il y avait cinq qui par
cavalli ou trois qui va partir cavaliers
au 3g 4 je crois que c'est terminé les
amis le cavalier va jaillir en f5 c'est
terminé c'est terminé et maxime va aller
le chercher les poux une touche qui
partent
maxime qui a tout donné et qui va la
chercher en finale timofeievitch
abandonne extraordinaire extraordinaire
les amis suisses sur huit maxime qui
revient et qui répond à ses détracteurs
c'est ce qu'on veut voir les amis quelle
victoire extraordinaire du joueur
français il lui a marché dessus les amis
c'est ça qu'on veut voir c'est pas
encore entérinée mais à mon avis c'est
un retard du site alors que magnus
carlsen l'a aussi emporté sinndar of
cuba mamediarov on n'a pas le buzz bec
et duda duda qui l'emportent contre
levitch ya un resserrement en tête les
amis maxime est au rendez-vous
aujourd'hui il est au rendez vous elle
grande des maximes qui revient à 6 sur 8
ça y est
maxime le diesel a démarré et
va être très difficile à arrêter pour
ses adversaires maintenant il est lancé
comme une fusée comme un frelon dans les
lignes ennemies et ça va faire très très
mal les amis
ça va faire mal ça va faire mal à la
gorge aussi il faut le souligner
il faut le souligner
il fait plaisir max 1 il fait plaisir il
envoie les game
il fait plaise
il fait plaise max
on va espérer un que ça avec sa clique 1
on va espérer que sa clique
on va voir s'il est si on rajoute au
classement est ce que ren shan ren char
a ajouté maxime au classement 10e ça
remonte karl scène est en train d'avoir
des gouttes de sueur sur le front est
devant c'est encore un ouzbek pas de
bluff côté ouzbeks
aujourd'hui à 12
du coup il reste 9 10 11 12 4 parties
il est pas là et caro attend
attendez on va chercher à carreaux
il est là il est derrière je le vois
je le vois il est il est un peu derrière
si vous regardez dans les rétros il ya
hikaru mais
si vous regardez devant il est pas là
faut aller vraiment vraiment à l'arrière
meilleurs joueurs deux villes du monde
mais jamais au rendez vous des grands
événements
terribles
terrible blanc
car ou dans les voitures est
qu'un maximum magnus les meilleurs sont
là en duda
terrible
tu auras gagné revient vous les voulez
qu'on suffiront à la prochaine on arrête
un peu de sucre maxime je suis peut-être
un peu trop un
c'est quand même dommage suivront peut
suivre magnus aussi si vous voulez
un dommage de suivre que maximin c'est
vrai
ouais
voilà on suit je sais pas on peut suivre
aussi ma mais où à peut-être dit bof
tiens regarde les parties de double off
est intéressant
au moins on fait des commentaires
objectifs
on peut tenter
on peut tenter un
un nom qui veut un vip tu choisis pas de
problème au grand lapin blanc qui se
présente sa charge du vip
au que oui
ça cherche le vip
c'est toi qui vois tu choisis c'est
magnifique roche cherche une
une promotion
j'ai à dire que depuis que je suis
arrivé même veulent à 2 sur 2 et voilà
ne part pas sarde surtout
ne part pas
maxime qui fait un taf incroyable il
faut gagner la prochaine encore et on
est vraiment dedans allez il faut tout
le temps gagner
en plus il vient de gagner deux fois au
noir maxime
21h21
ouais encore quatre aujourd'hui
maxime entre un employé à la strate
gagnant de gagner des parties n
ya pas encore les appariements de 49
et
inspiré par mur tu as même dans le
tournoi
il serait bon à prendre il a encore dans
les noms les plus à risque il n'y a plus
que des bons la 6 sur 8
ha minh basset maire il ya ici
à prendre
mam est
fort et jouer la mine
non il peut encore remonter mais bon il
ya un peu derrière
si maxime là qui va rappeler les bases
dans son cas serait beau qui gagne on
est loin encore mais on peut on peut
rêver en tout cas on peut qu'y fait en
suivant ce tournoi
je pense tu raccroches équipe du top 20
karl scène
carl scène les autres pas sûr
que baky a battu à possible qu'ils
abattent urba oui je n'aime pas qui
rappelle les bases 1
bat qui rappelle toujours les bases
pourquoi elle a aucune chance top 1000
alors conques le top 100 je veux bien
série nommée contre le top 1000 va quand
même peut-être pas abuser
non je peux rappeler les bases avec un
petit théo un
top 100 si tu veux le top 1000
faudrait jouer on va voir les
appariements peut-être ma mais ça peut
être bien pour maxime là maintenant aux
blancs
karlsson au moins c'est fait
ça comme ça représente s'ajoutent toutes
les demi heures ça c'est facile vers
19h30
un terreau 20h30
geo jacques convient-il
mais je sais pas
non
ces normes 49e
j'attends impatience et apparemment
ça va sûrement arriver là d'ici une deux
minutes
ça va partir en attendant la prochaine
game
dans les appareils j'y arrive pas
en sarthe
19h19 armella les appariements devrait
sortir d'une seconde à l'autre 1 je suis
étonné qu'il soit pas encore sorti
d'ailleurs
où est basée
dans le groupe nakamura
qui sont sortis maximy joue qui
quelques couleurs
au blanc fera si le jouet blanc c'est le
péno en faut le mettre
la miss est mon je sais pas qui
supportait frère
c
blake cela soit et pour ton coach
tebbane soit et pour maxime c'est un
choix complexe que tafer
c'est vraiment un choix difficile
c'est un choix très compliqué
je peux être pour le coach tu peux être
pour maxime
soit tu perds soit eban en fait et date
était mal on n'est pas bien
là on va
si mme harel est important de salles à
ce que là c'est vraiment l'appariement
pour revenir au top
tu as encore une cave n'y a qu' il ya
très peu de calme sur cet event
malheureusement
malheureusement ces quinze championnats
du monde donc il n'y a que trois
échiquier film et c'est
ça paraît quand même assez logique hein
ça paraît assez logique pour une
compétition comme un championnat du
monde
c'est assez normal
c'est qu'un championnat du monde reut
c'est logique en fait
surtout le tourin sûr
seulement aujourd'hui et demain le
dernier jour
chat est trop débile donc on va passer
en mode annie
parent soit
moi
une partie de ma fait une pub pour le
stage meanstream expérience une bonne
idée ça
ah oui on va envoyer un
il reste encore des places du coup on
essaye de un peu push au début
ça fait plaisir
ça fait 1
bon
balma mine basse m
à voir comment sa clique 1 je vais
m'assurer qu'on n'est pas là calmes de
maxime
c'est qu'ils
assassinent aof
c'est quand même dommage je peux avoir
les calmes jusqu'à la table 5
ça va partir
allez les amis allaient maxi blacks à
une partie vraiment importante ici me
contre contrat mine basse m c'est un
joueur qui est complètement à sa portée
six points sur huit qui peut faire la
diff maxime il envoie l'espagnol a une
nouvelle fois c'est toujours la même
ouverture l on part sur de l'espagnol
classique avec avec fuoh cette maxime
qui va jouer ces petits plans il les
connaît bien alors est-ce qu'il va jouer
avec avec ses trois tours et sai et
commence à jouer le répertoire amène mon
maxime
ça ne rigole plus côté maximus qui avait
l'équivalent des deux va peut-être
rebondir vers f1 pour aller vers 3
éventuellement taper sur les cases le
fou qui va venir à elle peut venir en b3
pour taper sur f 7 mai il s'exposera
cavaliers à 5 ou aller directement vers
ces deux pour préparer le le coût des
quatre maxime qui maintenant est en
grande forme a g6 pour mettre le fond g7
est à 4 ça y est il fait mal fou bessède
food et de ça va partir très
tranquillement il ya aussi b4 peut-être
ici qui peut être intéressant et food et
deux pour développer peut être aussi un
coup cavaliers ou trois aussi il ya
plusieurs options maxime qui prend son
temps au bon moment ici il mêle car à
lyon le 3 il tape sur les cases ça assez
bien joué
le fou qui vient g7 peut-être le b4
maintenant et le fou qui va rejaillir en
b3 qui va taper sur la diagonale
ça fait du bien
four b3 dame c2 qui peut partir le fou
qui peut aller en d2 ou en bep deux
tours à deux tours à le plan de maxime
est tout tracé amine bassem en légère
difficulté en ce début de partie c'est
là qu'il va falloir appuyé sur
l'accélérateur appuyer là où ça fait mal
s'il ya une plaie on va enfoncer dedans
c'est le but dans ce tournoi à présent
tekki un joueur un petit peu en dessous
il faut mettre le punto et quand on joue
contre des joueurs plus plus solide
entre guillemets il faudra savoir faire
preuve de modestie et prendre des demi
point mais là c'est vraiment le moment
où maxime veut pousser il a la position
pour le fou en b3 qui est bien la dame
qui va venir ans et de l'option eps vii
qui est un peu fragile la colonna qui
peut être joué aussi maxime qui a les
ressorts qui adéquat trop peut-être dans
la position et noir ont beaucoup plu
demain la aller chercher un dessin que
ça peut échanger il ya le le pion au
sein qui peut tomber après de multiples
échanges et je pense que maxime ici va
placer sa dame en c2 peut-être même tour
à trois dames à de fougue et de tours 1
peut-être qu'il peut stack toutes ces
pièces sur la colonne a pour rentrer en
force maxime qui échangent en réalité
en bessin qu il veut faire dams et de
maintenant est menacée fou prend f7
damas de dame prend 1,8 qu'il avait raté
tout à l'heure mais là c'est clair qu'il
va jouer son petit coup d'avancé 2 un
petit coup de marloux qui paye pas de
mine mais qui peut qui peut faire le taf
il peut aussi avoir du food et 2 1 dans
leur end pour aller chercher du dames 1
c'est aussi tout à fait possible et
damas est non il fait dame ces deux
quand même une mare loterie ça fait
toujours plaisir la petite menace damas
deux qui peut passer malheureusement je
vois pas vraiment de cou noir qui
laisserait ce ce piège marché en réalité
tous les coups logique noir comme
cavalier 17 dames cette
fougue et cette part est la menace de
maxime mesdames ces deux quand même bien
joué puisque lorsque la dame va venir on
a deux elle va taper sur le plan f7 elle
va aller venir se placer se glisser en
ascète ce cavalier qui pourrait
rejaillir éventuellement vers a3 rester
sur cette case aller en dessin qu'il
peut y avoir aussi du g4 h4 g5 pour
rentrer dans le lard et et bien s'en est
évidemment le plus simple tour un tour à
cette maxime qui a la position qu'ils
allaient pièce qui est bien placé mais
maintenant il va falloir augmenter cette
pression augmenter la chaleur parce que
amine bassem est un joueur solide très
tactique et il sera pas aisé de le
battre est de terminer la partie contre
lui mais elles font bessette il est
solide 1 pour le moment le joueur
égyptien je crois qu'il est docteur le
médecin qui est la fougue et cette tour
à 1 dames b6 et sur damas de il aura du
tour à 8 c'est sûrement ce qui va partir
d'ambea mais d'un v6 damas de 3,8 vous
prend à dans quel sens ça marche il ya
peut-être un truc en f 7 1 qui peut
partir il ya peut-être un ordre de coûts
pour maxime il va falloir le trouver on
va voir ce que joueur amine bassem sinon
c'est tour à cette dame à 2
les doses vont être prescrite par le
médecin mvl
d'amada tour à cette dame a deux qui
peut rentrer amin qui jouait la dame en
b6 est peut-être un petit tour à sinko
pour aller chercher du pion prend damas
de ces joué par maxime maxime qui
augmente la pression il ya un nouveau
problème dans la position pour les noirs
ces espions b5 cette dame qui fit l'on a
d'eux ce pion f7 ça commence à
scintiller côté côté noir ça commence à
être rouge de partout regardez-moi les
faiblesses thema la taille des
faiblesses le pion b5 qui va pas être
facile à défendre est-ce que lecavalier
pourrait revenir vers ses trois ça
pourrait être un plan c'est hyper
agréable à jouer aux blancs dame qui va
à la dame qui va venir on a deux il veut
cavalier e 6 et la tour qui va rentrer
en ascète il va chercher des csi mco
pour dévier la dame est allée taper le
fou maxime qui al'avantage dans cette
partie il ne faut pas gaspiller les
munitions alternée de gâcher une mission
c'est interdit c'est trop difficile à 6
sur 8 d'avant des positions comme ça
maxime dans l'obligation de faire le taf
est de gagner ici si on prend b5 il va y
avoir pu en prendre et 5 comprend b5 et
peut-être cavaliers d1 dames à deux
cavaliers c3 maxime qui est en train de
faire sa petite soupe minestrone il en
train d'aller taper le pion c6 s'il
faudra qu'elle quitté la casse bessette
a lancé situera du tour à 6 maxime qui
fait un travail exceptionnel dans cette
partie il est en train de mettre à mal
la mine basse m amine bassem qui va se
prendre le fois aux trois ça va être
difficile pour le joueur égyptien mais
attention c'est un excellent buteur il
est capable un ami de bassem de
d'opposer une résistance quand même
assez impressionnante mais là il ya
quand même beaucoup de problèmes dans la
position qu'a maliki arrive en c3 c'est
chose certaine maintenant le pion bessin
qui va être difficile à défendre le
cavalier peut pas bouger ya le pion à
vii en l'air il ya beaucoup de problèmes
côté amin il va falloir qu'ils trouvent
les coûts le joueur égyptien mais
peut-être que sur cavaliers c3 il veut
faire car et léger qu'un tri
contre-attaqué mais s'est vu par maxime
le petit h3 maxime solide qui laisse pas
de contre je amine et maintenant il va
falloir trouver les coûts quotas mine
c'est peut-être un des cinq qui peut
libérer le joueur égyptien tenté son
va-tout le tout pour le tout mais ça
fait peur il préfère faire tout recettes
et venir colmater le pion à vii la
septième rangée cavale et ses trois
fouilles poussées 6,6 des champions
maintenant la tourbe à rentrer en ahl si
slada mambé 7 le fonds est roi où il
veut dame des sept tours à cet ami qui
va être obligé de ramener la dame
jusqu'en b8 là-bas caché au loin au loin
cette dame mais maxime qui réussit pas à
nis a tapé b5 nihat apf 7 il va falloir
ramener peut-être ce cavalier en jeu
maintenant qui est plus forcément sur
les bonnes cases maxime qui on voit le
cavalier en d5 et prend des cinq fours
en d5 et prend des cinq dames prend des
sacs et il veut aller attaquer ce pion
bessette qui va être très dur a défendu
rap accueille ces sept là d'un progrès
si ces cavaliers tomber cette est
complètement forcé et maxime qui va
devoir trouver le coup
prêts maintenant il a le bon fou contre
le mauvais fond maxime cas ce cavalier
f3 qui est mal placé il va falloir
trouver les 15 h 4 h 5 qui veut aller
ouvrir les droits sur h5 et le cavalier
qui va jaillir angers 5 maxime qui est
en train d'avoir une position
exceptionnelle cavalli j'ai cinq
cavaliers prend h prend pour aller un
petit peu encore plus s'enfoncer son
adversaire et après la tour qui va venir
on assiste pour faire le taf sur le plan
des six mais le fou qui viendront et
fluide pour tous défendre la position
damine bassem à deux doigts de craquer
mais pour le moment il tient encore tour
à 6 fouet fuite damas deux maxime qui
essaye de passer encore par derrière via
du tour à 8 qu'est-ce qu'il est malin ce
maxime tours à huit dames c'est cette
satire encore pour les noirs c'est
incroyable la mine basse m qui fait un
travail défensif vraiment exceptionnel
dans cette partie mais le cavalier qui
va pouvoir peut-être jamais rangé cinq
tours à huit tours tours à huit tours b
8 tours à 7 tours bessette amine ben
hassen qui réussit pour le moment encore
à tenir peut-être que la tour va venir
en a six c'est possible on y reviendra 5
qui retape sur le pion maxime qui va
maintenant aller chercher un petit dame
b 5 peut-être pour remettre la pression
sur ce pion pour le moment à mine d'asse
m réussi à tenir mais il peut gaffe et à
tout moment le cavalier qui est parti à
angers 5 ça va échanger fou pranger 5 il
élimine encore une pièce y tape sur le
pion f7 à présent la tour qui revient la
tour de maxime qui va repartir
probablement vers la case à 8 essayez de
faire le taf de rentrer avec damas cinq
dames des huit maxime qui donne tout un
pur pour rentrer ma mine basse m et un
beau diablotins dans cette partie il
tient encore pour le moment mais y'a
plus de 5 secondes pour le joueur
égyptien qui va échouer autour des 7 il
veut faire des saints qui veut se
libérer de l'emprise de maxime et il
couvre la casse des huit c'est très très
bien joué de la part d'amis d'amd 5
maxime lui interdit de respirer puis on
prend pions prend il veut maintenant
tourbe et huit tours prend des 5 maxime
qui est proche de gagner mais amin qui
résiste encore aux et tour des baisers 3
quelle défense exceptionnelle damine
bassem dans cette partie il est encore
en vie à mine aurait vraiment il faut
lui tirer un coup de chapeau il faut
tirer un coup de chapeau à l'adversaire
ici mais peut-être des six fois fuite
fuglseth procès depuis on prend 1,7
maxime a vu le piège de marloux eu qu'à
3 et enfin maxime kyi qui défend il va
vouloir des six mamans et pousser son
pion le fou qui vient c'est 5 il colmate
où il colmate f2i colmate 3 il colmate
b4 il veut des six pour bien il veut
essayer d'aller prendre le pion à mine
basse m qui va les chercher
le pion b4 mais maxime qui va jouer des
sites vous prend des quatre prises
pistou rocettes
essayer d'aller d'aller jusqu'à dame
d'aller jusqu'au bout du bout
l'ordinateur donne le garrot maxime qui
ratent tour des huîtres ou des quatre
incroyable maxime qui rate le garant 2
et amine ben hassen qui revient dans la
partie c'est terrible y a encore poussé
5 ya poussé 5 les amis ya poussé 5 tu
peux le trouver il le trouve et le
trouve et le trouve les amis tu es
capable d'aller la gagner il est capable
maxime s'est trouvée par le joueur
français la finale c'est pas encore
gagné les amis il va falloir tout donner
mais le fou c'est 5 de marloux le fou
c'est 5 de marloux les amis il l'avait
dans son raid maxime il avait le fou qui
va revenir en c3 et maxime qui va monter
le roi et qui va aller s'imposer dans
cette partie c'est un maxime de gala
qu'on a ce soir aux contres jeu qui a
encore cherché par son adversaire on
sait pas si simple encore attention il
faut faire [ __ ] si si si c'est le seul
coup pour gagner
amine bassem qui qui sort une énorme
défense maksim qui rate le lien maxime
qui rate le gain iras tu fous et 6
incroyable incroyable joueur égyptien
qui va s'en sortir
[Musique]
incroyable maxime qui rate fouet f6
c'était difficile avec aussi peu de
temps à la pendule
incroyable et ça va défendre pour amin
incroyable joueur égyptien qui va s'en
sortir un magnifique défense damine bas
c'est maxime qui est à deux doigts de
l'emporter
à deux doigts et autant prêt ça va tenir
quelle malchance pour maxime dans cette
partie s'est pas encore fait un maxime
qui va essayer de faire un peu de ta
fmea fouet katia plus de chiapa des
chèques ale alors peut-être
alors être
est ce qui peut trouver quelque chose
et ce qui peut trouver quelque chose
d'amer trois
fous j'ai trois noms ces perdants non
non
maxime qui a complètement de choses
maxime qui a complètement autre chose
c'est incroyable c'est incroyable les
amis
maxime qui a complètement de choquer qui
s'incline dans cette partie
c'est incroyable
ah c'est incroyable
ça incroyable
fois m6 le coup de plus simple en plus
et de fou prend b2 et roy prend 2,4
incroyable
c'est incroyable
et après prend pas la nuit laissait de
la force et hyper
incroyable
incroyable un croiseur perdu ça c'est
ceci a perdu mais heureusement pour manu
ce qui reste à sa table
normalement oui mais après tout peut
arriver
normalement si je la perds je suis
dégoûté rêve
allez faut faire deux sur deux dans les
deux dernières et rester en vie dans ce
tournoi
c'est incroyable
après il fait pas nulles et julien c'est
dommage
le khimki pâques
[Musique]
15 cents a perdu aussi
d'avoir un peu le classement
c'est ça le classement c'est pas la mort
encore
mais bon là il était à sept points il
était donc la [ __ ]
rats fichiers fi des gains allez faut se
remettre
en plus il met enfin il perd la partie
qu'il a mieux joué le tournoi
sa meilleure partie du tournoi hyper
c'est terrible
parti et celle qui perd
à
déçoit
et celui-là je suis déçu
on va espérer un
wes aller il faut aller à fallait faut
se remettre faut absolument gagner la
prochaine
c'est terrible c'est terrible
foutu mais tu perds le corps on n'est
même pas à la moitié du tournoi
tu gagnes et de projets n'étaient très
bien
je vais mettre en mal la flamme à
souhait
c'est copier coller
ça a trop saoulé
non pas qu'ils perdent la suivante
allez on y croit encore
bah oui mais bon avec vincent on à la
pendule eu des coups évident on en rate
un
vous agissez un coup facile mais bon
mon avis quand je commande comme c'est
ce que je vois tout seul les coûts et ce
que je regarde avec l'ordi
13 c'est dommage
c'est dommage
la prochaine il était tellement bref
c'est tellement la balle de match quoi
enfin la balle de match la balle pour
revenir quoi
[Musique]
floués ben c'est la partie déterminante
là pour maxime s'y perd le tour est
terminé je pense
ouais c'est rien elle est partie mais
bon
nul ça peut encore aller ça dépend si le
blanc au noir
en vrai
au noir s'y fait nul c'est pas
gravissime
mais gagner mieux mais le problème avec
maxime c'est qui peut avoir une tendance
au turbo troll
c'est dur de
comme ça faut avoir un peu de beau lui
et gagner
il faut il faut encore vibrer
ouais contre max flou à l'aller 1
maxime peut le faire
non mais là pas trop de retard
s'ils gagnent 6 fait deux ans et demi
sur trois en fait il est dedans
parce que devant c'est pas aller enfin
il ya des formes ya pas que des forts
donc il peut il peut remonter
tiendra absent à nice c'est un gars
contre qui j'ai beats et ya pas
longtemps il est pas mauvais votre 2009
sur czech com
si par la prochaine finito pas forcément
finie tout finito mais oui juste et dur
dans la tête tu pourrais revenir mais
c'est dur dans la tête
la fois gagner
quelle nulle va aussi
il faut sur 21
15 15 et demi je pense
j'ai pas 15 et une oui
je pense 16-17 possible je sais pas
assez dur à dia
16-17 ça me paraît beaucoup quand même
mais bon
à m faut faire deux ennemis sur trois là
et on est bien parce qu'en vrai huit
ennemis sur 12 c'est cool aussi
les vingt-sept et demi et
sa clique
ballack a recensé c'est vrai qu'il est
très avantageux je vais te reste établi
gérer c'est pas sur un mariage forcé
déjà terminée elle tend mois
ali reza et plus ou moins marois
des fans de foot a mené tout le match
mais c'est un peu ça en vrai
à la fin dans une chance de faire mieux
li va faire dame en fait je faire dame
prend prises et
dames
il faut vraiment vraiment serré s'il
gagne la prochaine vraiment il se remet
elle est déterminante pour rester en vie
à l'instant c'était une partie pour
vraiment se mettre dans l'île assez pour
rester en vie
on va voir on va attendre
avant s'asseoir
aucun sens
tout à blain quoi qu'il en soit tout le
temps
mais maxi il peut gagner là c'est dans
ces moments là qu un peu de réussite
positive il a eu une grosse réussite
négative
il faut une réussite positive maintenant
maintenant il faut une visite une
réussite positif
allez ça va partir
allez il faut que maxime s'accroche
allez sa part meine aussi un qui doit
sauver sa vie dans le tournoi maxime qui
a faim d'appariement facile une nouvelle
fois maclou mais y at il des
appariements facile dans ce tournoi et
on lui envoie de nouveau à assystem de
londres alors là il n'y a pas trop de
ces signes qu'on va voir ce que maxime à
préparer contre le london eu 6 il va se
garder le fou cacher et food & cie soit
il joua il joue la bonne variante y joue
une bonne ligne ici
il joue une bonne ligne et s'avère ça a
peut-être joué au hockey joue cavalier
ou 5 c'est ce que je joue moi allez rock
ces cinq dames ses sept cavaliers 17 il
a regardé trop de free maxime pour ne
pas connaître cette position
il a regardé trop de stream qui a laissé
six dames 7 qui avait 17 aussi un bon
plan il ya zéro problème allez faut pas
hésiter à prendre une petite nul ici
récupérer
c'est dur dans la tête mais nul n'est
pas n'est pas mauvaise d'un message
crois que c'est pas vraiment le coup la
dame je pense qu'elle vient plutôt ans
et 7 pour taper mais je peux me tromper
hk c'est une nouvelle manière de jouer
j'avais perdu contre plusieurs parties
contre ça doit ni
je pense que la dame est vraiment mieux
placé ans et 7 quant aux 7 parce qu'elle
doit taper sur cinq
je suis un petit peu inquiet pour vous
dire la vérité
faut pas que maxime se désunissent faux
patrol c'est là qu'il faut être fort
c'est là qu'il faut être très fort je
pas comment on se débarrasse du cheval
du coup est-ce qu'il ya du cavalier 17
dans leur haine je mets ça peut faire
peur de la dame peut débarquer en h5
qui étaient sept sur un coup que je
regarderai vraiment
mais oui le truc les en fait s'est il
fait dames c'est cette maintenant
bon il vaut mieux que tu dis ah tu
disais mais il reconnaît son erreur mais
il avait vraiment pas le choix adam set
c'était vraiment un très mauvais coup
et allez faut mettre le cavalier e 4
faut aller éteindre ce fou ouais c'est
bien ils étalent incendie
allez ça va ça va ça va hisser il s'est
sauvé
il s'est sauvé pour le moment maxime
lecavalier qui vient à eux quatre
et c'est vrai que les noirs
m pression sur f2 ça c'est plutôt cool
et sur dame ces deux têtes il peut jouer
du f 5 vraiment venir installer ce
cheval quoique mais même si c'est
peut-être une option est sûr qu'il va
déprendre fou prend un f4
aller maxime pas si mal finalement dames
7 h quatre dames c'est cette ça va pas
si mal tourné pour lui
maxime qui joue qui joue les coups
maintenant
on va voir si
si réussi à faire mal il va prendre f4
en premier ses adversaires affaire qui
aura lieu cet intermédiaire dame prend
1,7 on va avoir une position assez
étrange au final ce fou c'est 8 va être
mauvais le cou aux 5 va être difficile à
jouer il fait cavalier ou 5 vous prend
1,5 et prend 1,5 et si c'est peut-être 5
maxime peut peut-être ouvrir la position
et ramenez-les fois angers 4 c'est
risqué c'est dur à faire et à juger
surtout quand on vient de perdre les
parties précédentes mais il peut
peut-être y avoir quelque chose
d'intéressant la faire pour le joueur
français à noter que si un jour toutes
les cases s'ouvre sur la diagonale sur
dame pétron pour avoir des c4 bon c'est
très lointain après beaucoup d échanges
mais fou prendre cavaliers prend un f6
cavaliers f3e 5 puis on prend puis on
prend fou prend 1,4 comprend quatre
dames b3 il aura ses 4 à la fin
info prend 1,5 jouer
j'aime bien la position de maximo finale
aller si celle-là tourner en sa faveur
il aura un petit quart d'heure a pris
pour bien récupérer pour se remettre la
tête à l'endroit
est allé mettre des tête à l'envers et
la position
est assez bien de manière inespérée ça
ça peut redonner confiance à l'essai un
clin d'oeil du destin qui te qui te
laisse en vie
les maximums maxime cas la position mac
sous l'eau qui réfléchit beaucoup match
nul doute qu'ils se met dans le mal qui
se met dans le dur
ouais ça fait là il est il doit quoi il
doit être à moins d'une minute le frérot
il doit être à moins d'une minute match
ou de l'eau et dans l'autre les durs
j'en prends un f6 maxime qui s'ouvre la
position qui va aller chercher du pion
prend en tout reprend eu 5 fu g4 j'aime
cette position maxime qui est mieux
allez on croit en lui il retrouve les
coûts là il lui manque un tout petit peu
de punch mais il a les coûts maintenant
fou 17 qui part il se développe il va
vouloir doubler les tours f6 g6 pas de
problème on affaiblit sur cases noires
mais on colmate bien maxime qui menacent
puis on prend 1,5 à présent match nul ou
qui va devoir prendre une décision ici
prend tout reprendre tour f 8 e 5 fu g4
ça peut partir très vite maxime à une 40
contre 35 secondes à laymont max pour
rester en vie dans ce tournoi pour
continuer à rêver d'un titre de champion
du monde des grands tu peux le faire
tu peux le faire mon grand à la mcl ou
qui sait pas trop quoi faire dame c2 est
un bon coup ces six rock est la maxime
doit peut-être joué avec f simcoe parce
que sur pions prend il veut il veut fou
prend 1,4 qui on prend 1,4 écart allégée
5 matches ou de loups qui serait bien
jouer peut-être maxime doit trouver f5
ici
cook aime bien l'ordinateur mais qui est
difficile
il ya aussi du p5 1 qui peut donner
envie à maxime pour b4 plus que 11
secondes un pur param param en sueur
mais parham encore en vie b 5 qui part à
5 sai et maxime envoie les punto ch il
joue logique il joue simple et il met la
pression sur match où aller après b 4 à
4 baies 3 ok match où le loup qui se
chauffent prise f6 prise m6 prise h et 3
h huit cavaliers g5 à les maximes une
petite séance de barbelés et on revient
dans le tournoi ils menacent cavaliers
pro 6 maxime va sûrement jouer des tours
à huit il colmate f7 il colmate g7 il
colmate h7 pour le moment ça paraît très
solide pour pour maxime il pourrait être
tenté aussi par un coup comme fou et 8
il a fait tout retour a eu huit tours h4
max hulu qui essaye de mettre la
pression c'est assez bien joué il a
retourné la situation
la position reste bonne pour pour les
noirs mais très difficile à jouer et
malgré le le déficit de temps les les
coups viennent facilement côté côté
macho de loups côté côté blanc maxime
pourrait être tenté par un coup comme le
5 ici est très très bizarrement
l'ordinateur d'un de gros avantages
blanc maintenant mais c'était c'est
vraiment un manque de réussite là parce
que les coûts de maxime sont logiques et
maxime complètement foutu il a raté
cavaliers f7 c'est terrible tampon fc
est temps qu'on arrive cet abandon
maxime qui va passer à travers c'est
terrible c'est des images terribles
maxime s'incline
maxime s'incline dans une partie très
mauvaise de sa part
très très mauvaise partie 5 et avait
trop de pression trop de menaces sur sur
g7
il a très mal joué le destin aurait pu
lui sourire mais ça n'a pas été le cas
on va aller voir ce que fait magnus mais
c'est la grosse déception manu c'est
gagnant 1 lui va revenir dans le tournoi
bien évidemment
il a eu un appariement tellement plus
facile aussi kobalia mais bon c'est pas
c'est pas ça le problème ici
terrible désillusion terrible
désillusion les amis
et ils karouf maxime au fond
hikaru qui lui aussi va remonter maxime
qui passe à côté
cette partie contre amine
aura été
déterminante on sait que maxime est une
tendance au tilt
et la whey 6 pour 1 sur 10
il a pas réussi à se remobiliser j'ai
pas vraiment où il a perdu la partie au
final
c'est une immense déception
savez quand même l'air assez pipeau un
way juste cinq ans fait
ça dégoûte
c'est pas gagné et en mer
huit sur dix ont encore des chances
petit 1
et pourquoi pas fait cavaler hc
directeur est il y avait un problème qui
est hc direct
dame g7
ouais
ouais c'est parti contre amin
maxime qui est un joueur qui a du mal
quand il n'est pas en confiance a bien
joué c'est un de ces petits défauts
wes un de ces petits défauts à maxime et
il a du mal à se ressaisir
elle
pluton tourner autrement mer
complexe
dommage dommage
enfin un petit peu prendre le contrecoup
je commenterai un peu plus
tranquillement du coup les deux
dernières rondes c'est plus maxime
un peu économiser ma voix
alireza n'est pas bien non plus
ga mc coup le moment il est il est loin
assure aussi
date pour avoir un joueur français qui
va remonter sur les deux
c'est terrible
de son assise soit ils sont loin sur 10
très loin
ça tilt ans at il dit
6000 et moins un clinic qui avant quoi
s'est il ya quelque chose qui est plus
pareil
il ya quelque chose qui n'est plus
quelque chose de cassé
dans les verts rapides et les
glissements l'important après c'est qui
c'est qu'ils se ressaisissent en ligue 1
on s'est peut-être l'aja prussiens
mais pas aller plus haut si cette il a
aussi perdu cette aura qui faisait que
les autres avaient peur
l'impact a ainsi quand même sarde
puis tu montes dans l'âge plus il faut
de la discipline puis faut un plus c'est
dur de rester en fait
plus tard en hommage plus c'est dur mais
il ya moins de femmes ans des positions
réfléchir et même plus qu il gagnait
c'est dur de rester haut niveau pendant
pendant longtemps et d'être régulier
plus tu avances plus à demandes
d'efforts en fait
bon faut gagner il faut qu'il gagne et
si gagner deux dernières 8 sur 12 demain
il y aura un petit à peut-être une
petite vibration
mais bon là c'est dommage qu'en fait si
la
whey ces petites absences quoi
rien qui se présentent mais rien n'y
fait un gros tournoi pour le moment
après 1
duras
on suit encore
chen dernier espoir
super on quit
on espère quand même
je passe qu'ils ont fait devant
honnêtement mais bon je vais commenter
plus tranquille à juin peux me reposer
rien commenté comme ça c'est vraiment
épuisant et les journées sont longues et
se fait déjà cinq heures de commentaires
c'est long
je peux avoir les résultats ça bug
donc il faudrait qu'ils gagnent quatre
parties la d'affilée quatre victoires
d'affilée dutreux place mais bon
tu te replaces simplement faut encore
continuer après faire genre 6 sur 7 kw à
6 ennemis sur 7
yuki à la prochaine